the SCP Foundation does their best to
live up to their famous namesake they
secure and contain anomalies and
monsters from all around the world or
sometimes even off-world and protect the
public from the dangers that these
strange entities might pose however
despite their efforts to maintain
security and keep their subjects under
lock and key there are sometimes
creatures so clever so devious and so
determined to escape their captivity and
wreak havoc on the world that even the
SCP Foundation struggles to keep them
from getting free one example is
scp-035 or the possessive mask
scp-035 is one of the most dangerous
test subjects in SCP Foundation custody
and its mere Presence at the foundation
has resulted in Untold damage death and
destruction it seems innocent enough to
the untrained eye The Mask which
resembles a classic white porcelain
comedy mask though it occasionally
changes its expression to tragedy as
been in existence since at least the
1800s
in the late 19th century the foundation
discovered the mask in a sealed Crypt
beneath an abandoned home in Venice it
is unknown how it got there or how the
foundation knew to look for it if there
was ever an explanation for its
discovery that has long since been
removed or redacted from The
foundation's Archives
you're probably wondering how can a
simple mask leave multiple season
Foundation employees dead well like
everything at the SCP Foundation this
mask Is Not What It Seems there's a
reason its classification is ketter a
designation that refers to an entity
that's excessively difficult to contain
and it couples this difficulty with a
pronounced hostility towards human life
and the ability to cause widespread
destruction in the event of a
containment breach
these are the qualities that the Poor
Unfortunate Souls assigned a guard
scp-035 would come to understand all too
well the possessive mask is a parasitic
entity constantly seeking out a host
willing to put it on any human being in
the mask's proximity experiences a
sudden unexplainable urge to put it on
and once they do There's No Going Back
SCP Foundation research has determined
that once a host has put on the mask
their brain waves are replaced with an
alternative pattern this one coming from
the mask rendering the host effectively
brain dead once the host's brain
function has been eliminated the mask
takes over piloting their body and even
speaking through them however the mask
can only occupy a host for a small
amount of time before the body begins to
Decay and decompose eventually rotting
away completely leaving nothing but
desiccated Flesh and Bones where there
once was a person
scp-035 is capable of possessing any
humanoid being whether that's an actual
human being or a life lifeless humanoid
shape despite all their research the SCP
Foundation unknowingly gave the mask all
the tools and resources it needed to
break containment and leave a trail of
bodies in its way for a Time the mask
was given host privileges meaning that
it was purposely allowed to occupy a
host in order to speak with the
scientists studying it in order to avoid
murky ethical issues the host was
usually something inanimate like a
mannequin or a statue these conditions
however unsettling allowed the
researchers to carry out interviews with
the Consciousness housed inside the mask
in the hope of beginning to understand
it and its motivations however
scp-035 lost all access to its host
privileges after it almost pulled off an
unprecedented shocking and nearly
catastrophic escape attempt
in its early days at the facility when
it was still allowed host privileges it
was contained in a triple locked room
and monitored by several research
Personnel these were experienced
researchers who had been with the
foundation for a minimum of five years
each an unusually long tenure in such a
dangerous and mentally corrosive line of
work these research staff members were
thought to be the most capable of
handling interactions with the mask and
be able to resist its attempts at
manipulation unfortunately these
assumptions were naive and seriously
underestimated the mask's power research
on the mask indicates that the mask is
incredibly intelligent and a skilled
manipulator it has a photographic memory
intelligence that would rank it in the
99th percentile of humans and the
ability to incite dramatic changes in
the behavior and people that it talks to
one particularly in famous interview
between the entity and an unnamed doctor
at the foundation suggested that the
mask may even possess telepathic
abilities the mask was able to give
details about the doctor's life that no
one else was privy to including
knowledge of an affair that his wife was
having following the interview the
doctor suffered a psychotic break and
committed suicide just 24 hours later
the mask is able to use its Superior
intelligence charismatic personality and
mind reading abilities to get inside the
heads of those it speaks with it pull
out any and all psychological stops to
get What It Wants leaving Broken minds
and Spirits in its wake
it was really only a matter of time
before it used this skill set to its
advantage and attempted to escape its
confinement the day of the escape
attempt was like any other the research
staff a team of three intelligent
experienced men checked into the
facility measured the conditions of the
mask's containment unit and began the
process of interviewing The Mask like
normal its motions were slow and looked
to require great effort as its current
house was beginning to degrade Beyond
use the mask was attached to the blank
face of a mannequin and corrosive black
liquid could be seen oozing from its eye
and mouth holes this liquid is excreted
by the mask at a near constant rate and
it's thought to be at least partially
responsible for the accelerated decay of
the host's bodies in spite of the
entity's unsettling nightmarish
appearance it was just another day's
work for the men assigned to Monitor
scp-035 and so they carried on with
their daily routine
everything was going according to plan
until one of the men Dr Jones began to
behave erratically he demanded that his
fellow scientists leave him alone with a
mask for a while and allow him to engage
in a private conversation with it it is
unknown what exactly the two spoke about
while the other two scientists were
absent as the security footage captured
had no sound however several minutes
into the conversation in the footage Dr
Jones can be seen dissolving into a fit
of Tears laying on the ground and
shaking with songs as the mask
dispassionately watches
he then climbs onto his knees begging
the mask for something before he
Embraces it he holds the mannequin in
his arms for five straight minutes
weeping again before they separate
after this disturbing emotional display
Dr Jones brought the other scientists
back into the room with him
what happened next is still uncertain
but there are a few things that we know
for sure the other scientists began to
speak with the mask in later interviews
the other scientists were bordering on
incoherent babbling about various
traumas from their lives one repeatedly
referred to a drunk driving accident
where a dear friend was killed and he
fall another simply cried out for his
mother again and again whatever the mask
said to them it was enough to completely
destroy their mental health after The
two scientists had been emotionally
devastated by The Mask Dr Jones
escalated the situation further Dr Jones
removed the mask from the decaying
mannequin body and shocking everyone who
had later reviewed the security footage
placed it onto his own face once the
mask was in place the security footage
ends at the command of the Mask which
was now speaking through Dr Jones the
other two men switched off all security
camera monitoring scp-035's containment
facility
The Mask piloting the body of Dr Jones
like a horrible fleshy puppet made its
way through the facility avoiding
detection until it reached the exit
doors
where it was finally stopped by a team
of over a dozen security guards knowing
the dangers of touching the mask all
Foundation employees involved in the
recontainment of scp-035 refused to
remove it from Dr Jones face instead he
was placed in the lock room with the
mask still on left alone to be observed
over the security cameras until his body
had decomposed Beyond use his body paced
back and forth in the cell for days
flesh rotting and dropping away only
until sinew and Bone remain only when
the bones began to turn black and
brittle crumbling apart into dust did
the body finally stop moving his family
was notified the mask was carefully
removed from what was left of his body
and his room
the other two scientists involved in the
scp-035 Escape attempts were terminated
and her files destroyed after this
incident a few more failed Escape
attempts and the acknowledgment of the
devastation that could have been caused
if the mask had made its way out into
the general population
scp-035 lost its host privileges
altogether several research staff
protested this decision insisting that
there was more to be learned from
speaking with the entity and citing
valuable information that it had given
about other scps however the risk was
determined to considerably outweigh the
potential reward and the request to
reinstate 035's host privileges were
denied
several staff members went so far as to
erupt into violent outbursts on zero
three font's behalf attacking their
supervisors who refused to provide the
mask with a new host clawing at them
with animalistic rage any staff members
that submitted a request to reinstate
said privileges were considered a
security threat and reassigned to a
different SCP or in some cases
terminated any staff member who had
Direct contact with scp-035 was also
terminated in order to avoid the risk of
any more staff aided the Escape attempts
the mask is now kept in a hermetically
sealed glass case there is a
psychologist on call to provide
assistance to anyone guarding it in case
of adverse effects on their mental
health from the mask's presence
Personnel that work around the mask even
in its current dormant State The
Experience frequent violent outbursts
and a higher rate of suicide even
without a host the mask's corrosive
effects have spread across its
containment facility the walls of the
room have begun to secrete the same
black liquid that emanates from The Mask
which tests have revealed to be highly
contaminated human blood that damages
the structural Integrity of the walls
following prolonged contact this blood
has begun to form patterns on the walls
spelling out words and phrases in
Italian Latin Greek and Sanskrit as well
as depicting drawings of ritual
sacrifice and mutilation staff members
also report hearing unintelligible
whispering and horrifying high-pitched
laughter when in proximity to the mask
further exposure to the mask results in
migraines hemorrhaging around the eyes
mouth and knows and an eventual
psychotic brain between the corrosive
substance appearing on the walls and the
physical and psychological damage to
employees
scp-035 is becoming increasingly
difficult to contain and there are
debates among staff as to whether the
entity can in fact be contained at all
as soon as possible
scp-035 will be moved into a new
containment facility and its previous
cell will be isolated from the rest of
the foundation's property and destroy
for the safety of all involved we can
only hope that the new containment
procedures are more effective than the
last ones and that this mask never makes
its way into the world again if it does
who knows how many lives it will claim
in the meantime if you ever come across
a strange mass and feel a nearly
uncontrollable urge to put it on ignore
the whispered please to just try it
ignore the echoing laughter and The
Sensation of something older and more
powerful than you can imagine rummaging
through your deepest darkest secret
thoughts turn around and run as fast as
you can in the other direction
you'll be glad that you did the desert
is still the night seems endless silent
and at peace until it's pierced by the
sound of gunshots and screams
deep in the Sahara the SCP Foundation is
Waging War against a newly discovered
enemy a squad of foundation agents is
retreating trying to get away from the
ones who massacred their allies they
were attempting to eliminate the threat
using conventional means but their
rifles were no match for the reality
bending entities of the kingdom of
Abaddon the retreating agents cover one
another as they make their way back to
the extraction point the enemy Force
advances agents that are caught too
close to the Sorcerers of Abaddon
disintegrate Into Thin Air this is not
an enemy they can defeat the SCP agents
need to get back to base and relay what
they have found to their superiors
out of the hundreds of Agents sent into
the Sahara that night only a handful
make it out alive they are debriefed by
their superiors at the foundation who
classified the anomalous humanoids under
the highest of threat levels the kingdom
of Abaddon is a threat the kingdom of
Abaddon must be eliminated
reconnaissance done prior to the
disastrous Mission had alerted the
foundation to the presence of anomalies
in the region but they had no idea how
strong the anomalous humanoids would be
from data gathered through old reports
it seemed like the Abaddon humanoids
were responsible for the deaths of no
fewer than 75 Foundation personnel and
had stolen at least 12 different items
from the foundation the leaders of the
SCP Foundation tasked research team
omega-5 with developing a weapon that
would be capable of destroying the
kingdom of Abaddon once and for all the
weapon they are researching must be
capable of long-range destruction
because the moment any foundation agent
gets close to the area they are
vaporized by the reality manipulating
powers of its inhabitants the project is
given the name twins of God and is led
by a foundation doctor known only by the
designation
051 051 is popular in the SCP Foundation
well known for his in-depth research and
charismatic personality making him the
perfect person to lead such a project
and o51 recently came across an anomaly
that he believes holds the solution the
foundation has been looking for to
defeat the kingdom of Abaddon item 001
and so the omega-5 team gets to work
they discover that the anomaly has
incredible Powers when put inside a host
which they refer to as an item 001
entity and set up a series of
experiments using different people to
harness its energy the first series of
tests all end in tragedy the anomaly
causes the entity it inhabits to become
intensely radioactive anyone who gets
close to it succumbs to immediate
radiation sickness and eventually death
to stop the radiation problems the
omega-5 research group intensifies the
containment procedures o51 receives
reports from the higher-ups that the
kingdom of Abaddon has attacked another
Foundation facility in Sudan long-range
defense is needed ASAP the administrator
puts more pressure on omega-5 and
especially its leader 051 to solve the
problems of item 001 and develop a
weapon that can save the foundation he
stays awake for days on end working
tirelessly to create a safe and
controllable item 001 entity although
there are signs that the weapon will
work it is still unpredictable when item
001 is initiated the host entity becomes
paralyzed suffers severe cerebral
hemorrhaging and soon a new host is
needed before testing Can Begin Again
and that's not the only thing that goes
wrong
whenever the anomaly is put into a new
host sudden and random destruction of
on-site structures and Personnel take
place o51 knows though that if this
power can be harnessed and controlled in
the right way that it could be the
weapon that the foundation needs to wipe
out the kingdom of Abaddon once and for
all in order to control item 001 o51 has
a mind kill switch implanted in its
host's brains o51 can activate the
implant to incapacitate its host and
immediately Stop The Unwanted
destruction countless hosts are
terminated by this mine kill switch in
the early trials conducted by the
omega-5 team but progress continues to
be made and eventually a hypothesis is
formulated perhaps the disastrous side
effects of item 001 can be offset by
spreading the anomaly across multiple
subjects they theorize that the immense
mental load of the anomaly can be
distributed among several hosts thus
reducing the toil it takes on each and
giving them the ability to control its
immense power but o51 and the omega-5
team need more data and for that they
need more bodies they consult with the
director of site 17 and it is concluded
that the nearby town of San Marco would
be an appropriate place to get the
additional test subjects they require on
a quiet Sunday morning
omega-5 along with support from a squad
of armed SCP agents Storm Into the San
Marcos de la Vida sterna Church during
the middle of mass they gather up a
number of the younger congregants and
bring them back to the site where item
001 is housed the researchers quickly
ran through their new supply of test
subjects though and omega-5 would need
to get even more if their research was
to continue
instead of going back and forth between
the testing facility and San Marcos 051
decided to move the entire item 001
operation to the town itself he renames
the town testing site 001 and omega-5
rounds up 23 of the healthiest subjects
they can find for use in the next series
of research tests a few weeks after
occupying the town of San Marco
omega-5 makes its most substantial
progress yet just as they theorized by
spreading out the anomaly of item 001
across a specific group of hosts that
can control its powers the test may have
cost the lives of almost everyone in the
town
but the ends certainly justify the means
the kingdom of Abaddon poses an
existential threat to the SCP Foundation
after all and thanks to This research
they will soon have a weapon capable of
bringing them Victory the foundation
administer criticized o51's methods but
can't argue with his results
unfortunately 051 has a dark secret a
secret that disturbs even the most
hardened and loyal members of omega-5 a
secret that has to do with the item 001
hosts the host that omega-5 has made its
major progress with are not the ordinary
test subjects normally used by the
foundation no the test subjects o51
makes his breakthrough with are children
nine of them to be exact all between 4
and 11 years old despite being told
specifically by the foundation
administrator to only test on adults the
research required 051 to break the chain
of command and follow the science down
the path it led the children are
contained in a reinforced bunker where
only 051 and a select few have access
they are technically alive but are
functionally brain dead the group of
nine children share a hive mind that can
process information and more importantly
can unleash the full potential of the
implanted anomaly creating and
controlling a devastating power but not
everyone is thrilled with what they've
achieved members of omega-5 are haunted
by the screens of the children that they
force to be part of their weapons
development program they describe their
merging with item 001 as being a process
that rips out their souls and replaces
them with something much more Sinister
in fact all of omega-5 regret what they
have been a part of and they've done all
except 051 the nine children can Channel
unprecedented amounts of energy from an
unknown origin that omega-5 hypothesizes
comes from an extra dimensional source
which is which is then used to unbind
atoms at the quantum level when the
right activation words are spoken it
appears as though this tremendous power
gives the children the ability to
annihilate anything in the entire
universe it's a gun to end all guns and
only 051 has the key to control it the
nine children work so well with an item
001 that omega-5 reclassifies it to
include the nine children themselves
they are not just the entity housing or
controlling item 001 they permanently
become item 001 once omega-5 has a
better understanding of item 001 they
begin to run tests to find out the full
extent of its abilities first they test
the distance item 001 can reach the
initial test that omega-5 carries out is
on a steel rod placed five kilometers
away 051 orders the children to destroy
the target moments later the phone next
to o51 begins to ring when he picks it
up the Observer tasked with watching the
pole is on the other end the informs o51
that the steel rod has been completely
vaporized o51 is not satisfied though he
has another poll sent out this time
placed 8 000 kilometers away from the
nine children 051 asked the children to
destroy that Rod almost immediately the
phone rings again the target has been
vaporized oh five one smiles the next
series of tests Omega 5 runs on item 001
are to determine the maximum size of an
object that can be destroyed the tests
start out with a steel sphere three
meters in diameter placed 1 000
kilometers from item 001 051 orders the
children to destroy the object it is
instantly vaporized o51 has seen enough
small tests it's time for something big
so he does something that will later be
questioned by everyone at the SCP
Foundation he orders the nine children
to destroy a church of the broken God
worship site in Turkey not long after
the destruction order is given to item
001 reports begin coming in the worship
site has been obliterated with no
observable damage to the surrounding
area
deadly and precise 051 closes his eyes
and takes a deep breath he looks as if
he's overcome by an immense spiritual
experience he opens his eyes leans over
to the children and Whispers the name of
someone later that day 051 finds out
that the target he had named has been
vaporized the success of omega-5 in item
001 is relayed to the administration of
the foundation they are so impressed
that they make plans to use item 001 to
eliminate the Abaddon threat once and
for all however one of the heads of the
foundation administrator Williams has
major concerns about the way o51 is
running the program the updates that 051
has been sending have become less
scientific and more philosophical more
spiritual administrator Williams sends a
letter to o51 reassuring him that he is
doing good work but once the mission to
destroy the kingdom of Abaddon is
completed 051 will be promoted to
director and reassigned to the newly
constructed site-19 for the good of the
foundation and maybe the rest of the
world he'll be permanently moved away
from item zero zero one o51's response
is short and to the point I am fine
administrator the project is finished we
will complete our task when
administrator Williams arrives at
site-001 a few days later he is greeted
by o51 and the omega-5 team Williams
can't help but notice that 051 has a
strange look in his eyes it is the look
of a crazed man who has been lost in his
work and who has perhaps lost himself
Williams puts the thought away though
and walks with o51 and his accompanying
agents to the viewing area where the
powers of item 001 will be demonstrated
administrator Williams and the other
agents watch from a protected viewing
room as 051 enters the Chamber of his
new super weapon it's time to see if
their weapon that has had so much time
effort sweat tears and especially blood
poured into it will have been worth it
everyone watches as o51 leans over and
says the name of the Abaddon Citadel to
the nine children all at once they start
to Glow no one observing can see what
has happened in the far-off Kingdom but
they know something big has happened the
administrator is thrilled but notices
something
051 hesitated the moment while leaning
over the children before standing back
up
he whispered something else to them and
then administrator Williams vaporizes
pulled apart at an atomic level before
he has the chance to scream what's going
on the agent standing next to where
administrator Williams previously
existed began to yell and pull out their
guns they burst through the door of the
observation room and run down the
hallway towards where 051 and the nine
children are located the arm agents rush
into the room but 051 is gone
nine children are still over the next
few weeks 051 is reported to be seen
several times by SCP agents however no
one is able to catch him and it appears
as though other members of the SCP
Foundation have also gone AWOL as well
perhaps joining him on the run it is
unclear what his plan is but the reports
from the reconnaissance team sent into
the Sahara make it obvious what the
result of his first command to the
children was there isn't a single
humanoid or building left in the Kingdom
of Abaddon
but even with this Victory the highest
levels of the SCP Foundation have an
ominous thought lurking in the back of
their minds where did o51 go and what is
he planning to do next
following the improper use of item 001
leading to the untimely death of a
high-ranking foundation staff member
the weapon was deemed too dangerous and
containment procedures were implemented
due to the high amount of radiation they
were found to admit the nine children
were placed into lead-lined bags and
buried under 50 meters of concrete
beneath the Church of San Marcos de la
Vida Eterna
though all the children continued to be
functionally brain dead they still
displaced Signs of Life despite their
containment and by order of the overseer
Council have been classified as a
formula entity it's a natural instinct
in many species to protect their young
and sometimes it's not just their own
babies but any young that look like them
regardless of your personal feelings on
humans earliest stage it is a scientific
fact that human babies are designed to
emphasize their own adorable
helplessness to make sure that other
older humans take care of them a baby's
cry is an inherently distressing sound
and when we hear it some deep Primal
part of us feels the urge to comfort and
care for the child until the sound stops
but of course we're talking about the
world of the SCP Foundation here where
there are bunnies that can eat anything
teddy bears that might steal your organs
to make duplicates of themselves and
chocolate fountains filled with
trillions of murder virus insects
Nothing Is What It Seems here and even
the most innocent and cute creatures may
be hiding A Deadly Secret
scp-734 being no exception today we're
talking about the baby this anomaly
proves that dangerous things can come in
small packages but where others only saw
misery and death the SCP Foundation saw
a certain potential Our Story begins in
the maternity ward of a hospital in the
USA where every medical professional's
worst nightmare was unfolding an unknown
but incredibly fast-acting flesh-eating
pathogens seemed to be running rampant
across the hospital's population it
began when patients who weren't even
admitted for Dermatological issues
started complaining of severe itches and
extreme skin pain some nurses and
doctors in the Maternity Ward began to
experience similar symptoms as well as
one of the infants leading to a massive
quarantine effort while the initial
symptoms first appeared to be limited to
severe pain and discomfort on isolated
parts of the skin the condition of The
Afflicted soon escalated their skin
began to messily flake off as the cells
comprising it lost physical cohesion and
died it was a kind of strange anomalous
rot that seemed to work inwards first
destroying the Integrity of the outer
layer of skin and then cause further
disintegration to deeper parts of the
body once the skin had shut off the
pathogen would turn its attention to
what was lying beneath Against All Odds
the disease affected organs muscle
tissue the vascular system and even
bones nothing was spared the victim's
bodies would completely break down and
they would be dead within a few hours by
the time the pathogen had finished
ravaging its victims what was left
didn't even look human anymore not only
patients but doctors and nurses that
have been walking the wards mere hours
before were now little more than piles
of human tissue sitting in what had
previously been their hospital beds
whatever this was it seemed like the
fastest progressing infection in
recorded history Hospital staff and
administrators were terrified this
appeared to be an entirely new disease
with a mysterious form of transmission
and worst of all no cure they were even
more confused when several black vans
pulled up outside the hospital and
mysterious men in hazmat suits Spilled
Out and began setting up a quarantine
Zone around the entire building whoever
these strange people were they
definitely weren't the CDC little did
the hospital Personnel know that this
was the group you'd never want showing
up and putting your location on lockdown
it was the SCP Foundation the infected
remains of the victims were taken away
for research purposes and the foundation
operatives immediately began conducting
debriefing interviews with Witnesses
they soon determined from a mix of
eyewitness accounts and Hospital
surveillance footage that everyone
infected with the mysterious pathogen
had all been in a particular section of
the Maternity Ward earlier in the day
and when the operatives investigated
this area they found another strange
detail an infant had no registered
mother present in the hospital the
foundation would later learn that this
was likely because the baby's mother was
the first victim of the deadly disease
after eliminating all other possible
options it seemed that the only
anomalous element that could have caused
all of this was the mysterious baby
though just how the mother even survived
carrying the baby to term was a mystery
in and of itself the baby was a
Caucasian male human infant between
seven and eight months of age nothing
appeared outwardly anomalous about the
child but they could confirm that every
single victim of the anomalous pathogen
had come into physical contact with a
child earlier that day everyone who had
been at the hospital was given amnestic
treatment and the foundation constructed
did possible cover stories for the
deaths that had occurred that day like
so many others before it the child was
secured and Spirited Away to the nearest
applicable Foundation containment site
there was reclassified
scp-734 and finally the real testing
into what precisely this infant was
capable of could begin physiologically
scp-734 appeared mostly non-anomalous
the infant had above average
intelligence and physical aptitude for a
child his age but otherwise showed no
mutations or abnormalities that would
suggest a Divergence from typical human
biology despite a vast array of tests
performed by the foundation into
essentially every aspect of 734's
biology they couldn't find anything that
hinted at the origin of the mysterious
pathogen but through some trial and
extremely costly error the foundation
was able to learn more about how exactly
the pathogen worked the only Vector for
transmission seemed to be direct contact
with the baby itself up to and including
the fluids and residues it leaves behind
those affected cannot transmit the
anomalous flaking effect to others
meaning the risk of an epidemic is
relievingly minimal but of course
accidents still happen as was discovered
when one agent misplaced her Sympathy
for the baby and decided to remove her
mask while interacting with him her
logic was that her masked face might
have caused the baby some kind of
distress and as long as she was only
coming into contact with him via her own
gloved hands everything would be fine
but some dust particles were floating in
the air at the time and scp-734 sneezed
in her face the agent began screaming in
pain and recoiling from the baby but it
was already too late her fate was sealed
she was taken to the infirmary and given
sedatives so that she could hopefully
die in as little pain as possible in
roughly 72 percent of cases amputation
of the affected areas has prevented the
entire body from succumbing to the
anomalous of effects of
scp-734 but this isn't exactly feasible
where the point of contact is the
victim's head within hours the agent's
flesh had flaked off her face leaving
her looking like a red bloody skull a
few hours after that she didn't have a
head at all throughout the
disintegration process of this
unfortunate agent the foundation took
grisly photographs these photographs are
shown to anyone preparing to work on the
scp-734 research project to teach them a
hard lesson on the importance of
adhering to proper safety protocols and
these protocols about how to deal with
the baby are incredibly tight given that
even incidental contact is often a death
sentence anyone entering the baby's
containment chamber needs to wear
contained atmosphere hazmat suits anyone
who makes physical contact with the baby
even when suited up is immediately
removed from the area and subject to
several hours of quarantine and
observation even inanimate objects that
have been inside the containment chamber
need to be thoroughly sterilized before
being removed given that even anomalous
children like scp-734 have very delicate
needs a Handler is always standing by in
full Hazmat gear to take care of the
baby these handlers are rotated every
hour to maintain alertness and safety
these handlers feed and change scp-734
regularly and sometimes even provide
toys that have been approved by the o5
council the foundation has gone to Great
Lengths to keep scp-734 alive and
comfortable because they believe that
scp-734 could be an important asset for
them in the future or more specifically
they see great strategic value in
scp-734's blood as mentioned earlier
contact with any matter from scp-734
triggers its deadly anomalous effects
including bodily fluids like blood but
unlike many toxic pathogens in this case
there is no risk of the the infection
getting out of control since the
infected do not become vectors for
transmission because of this the blood
of scp-734 can act as a powerful weapon
for both terminating anomalies deemed
unviable by the o5 council and
assassinating dangerous people who
belong to rival Grooms contact with the
blood would completely destroy the
target's body with no other anomalous
effects and no evidence of who exactly
conducted the hit
scp-734 has been fitted with an arterial
catheter so that the foundation can
collect large quantities of blood from
the anomalous infant every single week
for storage and research but it isn't
just the blood that the foundation sees
potential in
scp-734 himself has scored incredibly
well on the Esslinger loyalty index the
test the foundation uses to judge the
Loyalty of potential applicants to the
foundation cause as scp-734 matures if
these scores remain consistent he will
likely be trained to become a foundation
field agent in the future an agent
capable of killing someone with a touch
would needless to say be an asset to
certain covert missions that the
foundation would probably prefer to keep
off the books of course the SCP
Foundation recruiting certain compliant
anomalies to perform missions for them
is far from unprecedented the most
infamous of these is
scp-076 also known as able a
supernatural eternally resurrecting
swordsman and perhaps one of the finest
Warriors who ever lived the foundation
took note of this and channeled his
eternal thirst for battle into working
with his very own mobile task force he
could assist in missions by taking out
his bloodlust on enemy groups of
interest and dangerous anomalies however
this ended up working a little too well
and led to disaster Abel was so good at
his job that he burned through all of
his allotted Missions at astonishing
speed left with nothing more to do Abel
got antsy which led him to turning his
murderous desires on his fellow team
and then the foundation as a whole it
was an all-out Massacre before his
colleagues were finally able to kill him
and return him to containment the
failure of this initiative gave the very
idea of letting anomalies work for the
foundation in the field a bad name but
since then things have changed
especially with the establishment of MTF
Alpha 9. AKA Last Hope a new mobile task
force formed entirely of anomalous
individuals and their handlers these
consist of somewhat more stable
anomalies such as Abel's counterpart
scp-073 also known as Kane Kane cannot
be harmed with any harm befalling him
simply being mirrored back on his
attacker and his vast array of knowledge
makes him an incredibly useful
intelligent asset another of the several
members of Last Hope is Iris also known
as
scp-105 much like Kane Iris not only has
anomalous powers that make her immensely
valuable from missions in the field
she's also compliant and capable of
listening to reason unlike Kane her
abilities include being able to actively
surveil and even interact with photos of
any location especially when taken with
her anomalous camera someday scp-734
could count himself among other
anomalous Foundation agents like these
providing he continues to show promise
and doesn't develop a dislike of the
foundation as he ages since after all he
won't be a baby forever so if you ever
find yourself on the foundation's bad
side you have a good reason to be
paranoid you'll have no idea that one
day the man who's going to kill you will
approach and shake your hand with a
smile it won't be until later when you
feel that strange tingle on your palm
and feel the skin starting to flake away
that you'll realize you've been a dead
man walking for hours there's an app for
that
wait hold on I'm Steve Jobs
it was a phrase so ubiquitous in the
early days of the smartphone craze that
it's hard to believe Apple actually has
trademarked it was a testament to a
simple and immutable truth about the
world these new touchscreen phones were
creating no matter how strange and
obscure the need there would be an app
to fulfill it perhaps you remember iBeer
the app that allowed you to pretend you
were drinking a tall glass of beer for
some reason there was car matey an app
that reminded you where you parked your
car in a pirate voice and who could
forget I am bread a surreal game about
controlling a sentient slice of bread on
a quest to become toast but there's one
app out there somewhere on the market
that you probably didn't download and if
you did well you have our sincerest
apologies because even seeing this video
pop out onto your feed probably sent a
chill down your spine well if that chill
ever even left take it from one
gentleman whose life took a very very
strange turn after downloading a certain
app that the SCP Foundation calls
scp-1471 because the sentiment there's
an app for that doesn't exclude
experiencing mortal Terror Joe Lewis an
insurance salesman from Milwaukee had
just gone through another atrocious date
after a mediocre meal and an
uncomfortable 35 minutes of inane Babble
sensing the whole time that she really
wasn't that interested his date excused
himself to take a quick phone call
outside sadly for Joe she never returned
leaving him to pick up the check of all
the many words you could use to describe
Poor Joe Lewis the most pertinent would
be lonely ever since Carol his wife of
10 years had passed away in a freak
accident he'd been trying to find some
kind of way to fill the void they'd been
high school sweethearts intent on
spending the rest of their lives with
one another as fate would have it only
Carol would get that tainted luxury Joe
would forced to endure life after the
joy of living had run its course he only
hoped he might be lucky enough to find
love again however Joe was on the wrong
side of 40 and as so many others his age
were already hitched he could feel his
options going out one by one would he be
destined to live out the rest of his
days alone Joe didn't feel like spending
the back half of his life catching
reruns of Seinfeld and tending to his
fish he needed to get out there and
thankfully like the rest of us he lived
in the internet age he had more apps
websites online services and hot Russian
singles in his area than he knew what to
do with so surely one would have the
right person for him he tried them all
Tinder hingematch.com Plenty of Fish
e-harmony Bumble Zoosk OkCupid Friend
Finder deeply lonely singles with low
expectations.com and so much more
however all it seemed to achieve was
setting him up for more disappointment
none of the dates he'd managed to get
ever resulted in anything getting
serious heck it was a minor miracle if
he even managed to get any of them on a
second date was this it was this his
life now had he only ever gotten one
shot at love and the grasping claws of
Fate yanked it away from him without a
second thought would life continue on
the hamster wheel of loneliness sleeping
getting up eating working and sleeping
again every day getting somehow both
faster and slower as life trudged on to
a disappointing yet inevitable
conclusion what a terrible fate to find
yourself trapped in whenever Joe started
feeling modeling like this he knew it
was time to get proactive again maybe
the right woman was out there there were
billions of them after all surely at
least one of them would be the perfect
person for him he just needed the
perfect app he'd burned through all of
the most reputable apps already and was
now perusing some of the slightlier
seedier options most of which were
likely data mining fronts from the
Balkans however as generic app after
generic app passed something different
caught his eye the icon was a smiling
cartoon dog and its name was malau
version
1.0.0 this gave him a little chuckle at
the very least it was very different
branding from the rest of the dating
apps he'd seen maybe it just been sorted
into the wrong section of the App Store
he decided he'd check it out and take a
look at the app's description the
description read never settle for those
awkward feelings of being alone ever
again mellow is an exciting and
interactive experience that will keep
you engaged and intrigued the anxiety of
social situations can be nerve-wracking
but after just a few hours of mallow you
will soon forget all about those painful
emotions of disappointment be part of
the new craze that is quickly becoming
the next social substitute remember the
more you participate the more malau will
engage you your experience is complete
up to you absolutely no ads enjoy well
it certainly provoked Joe's curiosity at
the very least he did want to banish his
feelings of loneliness and seeing as the
app was free and apparently had no ads
he'd surely be foolish to not at least
give it a whirl what's the worst that
could happen he began the installation
and only then noticed that the app had
no listed developer it took up 9.8
megabytes of memory which he wasn't tech
savvy enough to see any issues with more
than anything Joe was just enticed by
the prospect of finally having another
chance at companionship with Malo after
all it is the next social substitute
whatever that means however Joe's
excitement was quickly quashed when he
hit the home screen button and noticed
that the icon for the app never actually
materialized strange he checked the App
Store portal again and saw that
according to them the app had completely
downloaded what gives was it a glitch or
was malau actually just malware either
way he was disheartened by the fact that
this immaterial app certainly wouldn't
be getting him any companionship or so
he thought anyway Joe was used to
disappointment by now so he didn't take
it too personally he decided to just
play out the rest of his evening on
autopilot making himself some soup doing
the laundry watching more Seinfeld
reruns taking a cold shower and
preparing to cry himself to sleep again
Malo was already becoming a distant
memory just like all the deceptive
sources of home but one strange thing
happened that disrupted Joe's finely
tuned evening routine he received a text
message this was incredibly strange
because nobody ever seemed to text him
the last text he got was from Carol just
before her accident so it was almost
surreal to hear that alerts sound now
after everything that happened he
checked and saw that the text was an
image attachment sent from an unknown
number perplexed yet curious he decided
to open it his curiosity soon gave way
to a kind of melancholy Nostalgia when
he saw that the photo was of his and
Carol's favorite Cafe in town they'd
spent many a morning there back when she
was alive treating themselves to a nice
cup of coffee and perhaps a croissant
just seeing it again caused an
involuntary smile to spread across his
face it never even occurred to him as it
probably would have to others that this
could be seen as a little creepy he
hadn't frequented the bakery since Carol
died how would anyone even know that
this place held any significance for him
was it a stalker a ghost or just a
spooky coincidence none of these
thoughts even crossed Joe's mind he was
just grateful for the surprising
reminder of the happiness he'd once had
for the next couple hours things seemed
lighter he went about his evening
checking the photo every so often and
smiling until eventually he found
himself in bed still looking into the
glow of his phone it was such a
beautiful little Cafe then he froze he
noticed something in the picture he'd
been there the whole time but only now
he was seeing rather than just looking
it was in the corner staring through the
glass of the cafe store so faint he
almost wanted to dismiss it as a trick
of the light it was a face well not a
face more like a skull not a human not
anywhere near human long slender and
canine with protruding fangs and vacant
white eyes the Pure White of the skull
was buried in a nest of thick black hair
it looked like it was crouching behind
the door looking out and grinning
whatever the hell it was just seeing it
change the entire tone of the picture it
was no longer a simple reminder of
bygone Joy now all that was radiating
out of that image was a palpable sense
of dread was someone playing some kind
of awful prank on him just then he was
jogged from his contemplation by another
alert a new message from the same number
as before with great hesitation he
hovered his thumb over the push
notification and clicked that's when
everything got a lot worse it was a
photo of a bus stop not just any bus
stop of course it was stop c16 the one
that Joe always took to get to work it
looked like it was taken relatively
early in the morning but nobody was
there well not quite nobody there was
that figure again it stood at full
height behind the partially frosted
glass that makes up the back of the bus
stop the same large black humanoid shape
with a white grinning dog skull where
the face should be something about it
terrified him on such a primal level
like the way our lizard brain reacts to
some ancient apex predator and whatever
this thing was it clearly knew something
about him how else could it stage all
these photos Joe got out of bed and
looked out of the window down onto his
dark front Street empty thankfully but
after this surprise nightmare he wasn't
going to take any chances he grabbed a
kitchen knife from downstairs and placed
it on his bedside cabinet right next to
his phone with 9-1-1 on speed dial Joe
lillis a 43 year old man slept with the
lights on that night for the first time
in over 30 years sadly for him the
nightmare was just beginning the next
morning Joe woke up unharmed but he
wasn't pleased to see that he'd gotten
several more texts in his sleep there
was one taken outside of the local
insurance company office where he worked
the strange creature with the skull for
a face was looming around the corner
peering at the camera with its lipless
grin like it was mocking him another
photo was taken at the local supermarket
where Joe did most of his grocery
shopping the frame was centralized on
the cereal aisle bordered on both sides
by walls of garish mascots endlessly
repeated down at the far end of the
aisle was a looming dark figure with
that cold canine skull where a human
face should be there were a few more but
worst of all was the last one it was
taken at the cemetery in the foreground
a headstone reading Carol lilis beloved
wife and daughter Joe was horrified to
see that skull face Beast was rising up
behind his wife's grave long clawed
fingers curling around the top of the
headstone that was the moment that Joe
decided to go to the police about all of
this before things got even more out of
hand he called an Uber to get down to
the station he certainly didn't feel
like he was going anywhere near his
regular bus stop after last night he
showed the photos he'd been sent so far
to an officer posted at the station and
they agreed that there was certainly
something strange about it while the
behavior undeniably bordered on
harassment it hadn't yet delved into
criminal territory so he would sadly be
on his own until then the best they
could do was stay in touch and cut
abreast of any new developments the only
Sage advice they could give was not to
delete the photos as they could always
be used as evidence in court later if
things escalated this was literally the
last result that Joe wanted out this
considering how bizarre and threatening
things were getting already he really
didn't want to find out what escalation
looked like in this case but what else
could he do but carry on just trying to
exercise as much caution as he could in
these strange news circumstances he went
to work and tried his best to stay
productive despite the fact that every
three or so hours a new photo would
arrive places that he liked to sit in
the local parks stores he'd frequent
restaurants he liked to eat at the
nightmare skeleton dog thing would be
standing in all of them just mugging for
the camera on one hand every time he
looked at one of the photos Joe felt
like he was giving this freak exactly
what they wanted on the other hand how
could he possibly Look Away what if he
missed something that could save his
life it carried on much like that until
later in the eve
Joe may have not been a genius but he
was no fool either he'd seen too many of
those seedy true crime documentaries
about kidnapping to take his normal
route home he took a real detour
frequently checking over his shoulder
the entire time much to his relief he
didn't see anything out of place good
when he got home he locked every door
and bolted every window nothing would be
getting the jump on him tonight that's
when the next picture came in a
photograph of Joe's empty office cubicle
with the Bony face of the creature
looming over the divider with a grin he
could feel his heart pounding away in
his chest just looking at it how did
this thing get around like this how was
it able to infiltrate everywhere in his
entire goddamn life suddenly he felt a
smile spreading across his face this
freak had just messed up big time before
all these creepy photos had been taken
in public places but the one taken in
his office oh this crossed the line into
trespassing the police would have to do
something about it now it had given him
an ace up his sleeve that confidence
faded a few hours later when he received
another photo this time it was the skull
face monster just standing on the
sidewalk the sidewalk that Joe
remembered walking on his covert
alternative route he could feel himself
break into a cold sweat it seemed
whoever this was he really did hold no
secrets from them now more than ever Joe
didn't feel safe in his own home so you
can only imagine how he felt when a few
hours later he received a photo of the
skull face stalker standing right
outside his own front door staring into
the camera it sent him rushing to the
window again to check outside but of
course nobody was there the next day
when he called the police and updated
them on the situation they told him that
they were doing all they could the best
thing he could possibly do was to remain
calm but Vigilant he needed to keep an
eye on the photos being sent to him so
he could notify them if ever he was in
any immediate danger this put poor Joe's
paranoia at a fever pitch even when he
went to work surrounded by his
co-workers by Witnesses he could
scarcely tear his eyes away from his
phone he was a slave to the photos
forever waiting for the next one only to
experience crushing regret when the
photo actually arrived it looked like it
was taken moments before it was sent to
him Joe saw himself looking at his own
phone in his office cubicle with that
huge skull-faced figure looming behind
him he screamed out loud upon seeing it
and turned to see if anything was behind
him but of course there was nothing
there the police inspected the office
talked to potential Witnesses and
analyzed the photo it showed no signs of
any photographic manipulation but there
were also no witnesses around the office
who claimed to see anything strange that
day there was also no security camera
footage in the last several days that
showed this figure coming in or out Joe
Louis started to feel like he was going
insane and perhaps he was but that
didn't change the tangible and
ever-present feeling that he was in
great danger he didn't come into work
the next day he'd received more photos
like that in the night of himself taken
in real time with that skull face freak
looming he didn't want to leave the
house he didn't want to go anywhere
anymore he just didn't feel safe out
there how could he with all this madness
unfolding there was a time where he
could have said something like at least
it only seems confined to my phone he
might have even suspected that it had
something to do with that strange mallow
app he downloaded a few days prior that
hadn't seemed to do anything but this
situation had evolved since then he
wasn't just seeing the creature in
photos anymore it was here he kept
seeing quick flashes of it on the other
side of Windows in Reflections in the
corner of his eyes always starting a way
if ever he turned towards it it was
everywhere and nowhere it was here just
for him he just knew the police couldn't
help nobody could help Joe just sat in
the corner of his bedroom clutching his
kitchen knife afraid to close his eyes
it could be anywhere it could be
anywhere it could be anywhere we know
one thing for sure Joe lillis never felt
truly alone ever again he always had his
new friend waiting just out of sight and
if ever you're feeling Lonesome and
decide to download mellow version 1.0.0
yourself then you'll never feel lonely
again if you have ever taken a trip to
Sun Top Mountain in the Mount Baker
Snoqualmie National Forest Washington
State then you may have come across an
old wooden structure the sun top fire
lookout built in the early 1930s the
building was used by the U.S forest
Service to keep watch for any fires in
the nearby Woodland at one point Sun top
fire lookout would have been manned 365
days a year complete with a bed for
staff who were stationed there on
rotation the single story Lookout house
overlooks the scenic valleys of the
White River and Huckleberry Creek but
you're not here for an informative
tourist guide you probably don't care
about the frankly fascinating history of
the lookout and how it was used as part
of the aircraft warning service during
World War II watching for enemy planes
no you're here because something much
darker lurks inside the Sun top fire
lookout and even though it appears to be
a simple one-story tall wooden structure
it certainly is not short on Space
scp-3333 refers to an anomaly that the
foundation discovered inside the Sun top
fire lookout house the building's
interior is a single Square Room
measuring 14 feet by 14 feet with large
windows on all four sides when standing
inside Sun top fire lookout looking up
at the wooden ceiling one will
immediately notice a trap door no big
deal right a lot of places have a
ceiling entrance to a small crawl space
there's probably nothing behind that
trap door apart from a Dusty old attic
there's a latch that maybe once had a
padlock there but not anymore opening
the trap door will reveal a collapsible
ladder should anyone be brave or indeed
foolish enough to begin to climb then
they'll soon find themselves right back
where they started inside Sun top fire
lookout or so it will seem the thing
about being in a place like the Mount
Baker Snoqualmie National Forest that
surrounds Sun top fire lookout is that
Woodland areas are teeming with life not
just plants and trees but birds and
other animals of the forest you can
never truly be alone in a setting like
that there is always life everywhere
around you so when you ascend the ladder
and climb right back into the sun top
fire lookout that is the first most
noticeable difference you will find it
may take a while at first but the
nagging absence of something unusually
so abundant in a forest will eventually
become obvious it's quiet far too quiet
no Birdsong or the sound of distant
calls from Woodland Critters just
silence all around anyone ascending the
ladder will find themselves in a copy of
sun top fire Lookouts interior one story
higher than the ground level of the
small wooden building with the stairs
leading up to the front door getting
taller each time to reach up to the
higher and higher building now you know
the SCP Foundation and the types of
bizarre interdimensional anomalies that
they're used to dealing with perhaps
scp-3333 is a mirror Dimension or a
plane of existence where sound doesn't
travel it certainly seems to be
identical to the sun top fire lookout
save for the lack of any organic life
outside of course it's what you'll find
living inside
scp-3333 that you may want to worry
about climbing higher up the next ladder
and through the next trapdoor every time
with the same result you appear at
another copy of sun top fire lookout
each one higher up than the last what
first seemed to be an innocuous
unassuming wooden building is now an
endless Ascension up into the heavens
towards the unknown in silence without a
shred of plant or animal life outside as
you climb perhaps you start to think
about how much higher these copies go
this might even be the biblical Jacob's
Ladder connecting Heaven and Earth that
would be nice wouldn't it if you were
gradually climbing your way up to
Paradise it might make it worth the trip
but scp-3333 is nothing that Pleasant
you wouldn't be the first to attempt
this long climb when the SCP Foundation
first discovered scp-3333 a research
detail set up an on-site base camp to
examine this spatial anomaly their first
exploration involves sending a member of
d-class personnel designated
d4f68a up the ladder his D number is a
hexadecimal code that when translated to
text reads oh so we'll call him that for
brevity's sake during the first day's
exploration o was able to climb 184
iterations of
scp-33333 communicating with head
researcher Dr Williams Below on the
second day o could see a pair of figures
standing motionless on a nearby Ridge
but the pair could not be seen by Dr
Williams and the other researchers at
the base camp both figures disappeared
shortly after o spotted them with the
camera he had been issued and he felt
uneasy almost certain that he saw them
point at him the next day at the 345th
copy of sun top fire lookout O's
Behavior started to noticeably change
previously he had been anxious about the
long climb and hadn't questioned
directions given to him by Dr Williams
now he seemed to speak more casually
resisting instructions asking Williams
to climb back down and even calling her
doc instead of doctor oh also reported
seeing writing on the walls but there
was no evidence of this on his camera it
appeared that something had started to
affect him it was when o reached level
527 that things seemed to change more
dramatically rather than scp-3333
continuing upwards the copies of sun top
fire lookout no longer had a trap door
or ladder they seemed to be arranged
side by side in a grid-like pattern
stepping out of the main doorway oh
remarked on the lack of sunlight and a
walkway that connected directly to the
front door of the next iteration of
scp-3333 O complained about the lack of
natural light and again requested to be
allowed back down Dr Williams instructed
o to use the flashlights he was provided
but they wouldn't activate and their
spare batteries had vanished oh then
noticed a sudden movement and just then
his microphone and camera feed went dead
almost as if someone had turned them off
it appeared that scp-3333 had something
else lurking up there Dr Williams
oversaw the second Expedition into
scp-333 this time members of mobile Task
Force Mod 0 also known by the codename
characteristic again spaces were sent up
the ladder they are sent through the
various copies of sun top fire lookout
were not as eventful as o's with no
signs of mysterious figures or anxious
feelings that o seem to feel as he
climbed when they reached level 527
where the copies of the lookout stop
progressing upwards and spread out in a
pattern instead their lights and
Equipment all seemed to be in working
order however as the MTF team split up
one by one they encountered some sort of
anomaly or an effect of scp-3333 that
caused each of them to vanish into the
dark either that or something took them
these MTF units reappeared confused and
mod 5 the team's leader Graham Purcell
issued an order to retreat and the
entire Squad went back down the ladders
for several days until they finally
reached the base camp again the members
of Mod 0 were adamant they did not wish
to climb scp-33333 again but Dr Williams
was beginning to understand more of the
anomaly's effects it appeared to cause
abrupt changes to people's personalities
along with some sort of phenomenon that
caused things to appear and disappear
The Higher One climbed assuming these
were the result of a memetic effect Dr
Williams dispatched a counter memetic
specialist for the next Expedition this
specialist was a blind deaf and mute
woman known as Annette or the null
Walker who communicated via signaling
system embedded in her hand but was
otherwise immune to any memetic
influences observed by Dr Williams and
Graham Purcell at base camp Annette made
her way to the top of scp-3333 reporting
that she was aware of someone watching
her from outside the copies of sun top
fire lookout honor body camera a flicker
of motion occurred something looking
through the windows that ducked out a
frame when the camera passed in its
direction at the Apex of scp-3333
Annette kept her flashlight off but
reported that she could detect blood
following it to what she assumed was a
body sounds of movement surrounded her
and as Annette switched on her
flashlight Williams and Purcell saw that
it wasn't a body in front of her instead
it was a pile of rotting organs
decomposing muscles and discarded bones
and among the pile was a metal dog tag
that read MTF mod 5 gram per se
the same man who is sitting next to Dr
Williams at base camp wow the same man
on the outside at least the explanation
for everything going on inside
scp-3333 all these strange occurrences
and disappearances finally came in a
video sent from Dr Williams's cell phone
in it a panicked Williams covered in
blood was fleeing from something at the
top of the recursive stack of
scp-3333 there was no memetic effect at
the apex of the sun top fire lookout
copies nothing was causing the people
that the foundation sent up to act
unlike themselves they simply weren't
themselves anymore according to a
frantic video Dr Williams had discovered
the truth about what else was hiding
within scp-3333 with just the right
amount of vagueness and Intrigue the
research team had been drawn in it was
as if they'd been lured in by the lights
of an anglerfish realize using their
Grim fate only too late the d-class O
the MTF team even Annette had been
replaced an unknown group of entities on
the top level of scp-3333 had been
carefully observing them waiting until
they would not be seen to slip in and
switch places these entities had been
creating imagined anomalous effects like
oh seeing figures that weren't really
there as a way of luring more bodies
further up the stack they wanted the
foundation to keep sending Expeditions
into
scp-3333 to keep them coming back the
mass of organs musculature and bones
that Annette had stumbled across
revealing the ruse had once belonged to
Graham per cell before he was replaced
you see the entities residing in scp-333
weren't just copying people they weren't
possessing them or mind controlling them
or even shape-shifting to steal a
person's life
they were taking skin these creatures
hollowed out gram o a net and the MTF
team pulling out their innards and
crawling their way inside filling these
fleshy puppets and leaving their
internal organs to rot these
hollowed-out people became vessels for
the entities of scp-3333 to hide in the
whole thing had been a trap
intentionally exploiting human
weaknesses Intrigue and unanswered
questions you know what they say about
curiosity and these entities used it to
bring more potential vessels to the top
of
scp-33333 they pretended to be the
people who they had replaced imitating
them so the foundation would send more
Personnel to explore the tower
increasing their supply of skins
Graham's dog tag had revealed the
deception and Dr Williams had escaped up
scp-3333 the members of the research
team that had already been Place were
hot on her tail determined to catch and
Hollow her out too and by the end of her
video they had succeeded a month later
though A Team delivering supplies
realized what had happened and the trap
door was sealed Sun top fire lookout was
put under permanent guard but at least
50 Personnel were killed or replaced by
one of the entities a new mobile task
force Lambda 1 Maxwell's demons was
created to hunt down and neutralize any
of the entities that had escaped
scp-3333 but it's still unknown how many
left the tower and are still out there
somewhere waiting to use someone's
curiosity about the strange and unknown
against them on a cold October night in
2003 Shirley Yates of Seattle Washington
was just about to get ready for bed when
she heard a knock at the door she
approached the door and asked the person
on the other side to identify themselves
The Voice outside responded immediately
it was a Salesman who just wanted a few
moments of Mrs Yates time this was odd
for two reasons first it was almost 10
o'clock at night much later than as
usual for door-to-door salesman and
second the knock hadn't come from Mrs
yates's front door it was coming from
the door to her bathroom has your home
ever been visited by a door-to-door
Salesman if you were born in the last 40
years then your answer to that question
is probably no in the age of online
shopping the idea of a salesperson going
from house to house Hocking vacuum
cleaners or encyclopedia sets Feels Like
A Relic from the past it's highly
unlikely you'd ever see one walking the
streets nowadays and equally unlikely
that one would knock on your front door
however if you live in Washington state
you might need to be wary of a certain
salesman who is still doing the rounds
scp-1879 also known as the indoor
salesman and the doorman is a phenomenon
that manifests randomly in homes
throughout Washington subjects will hear
persistent knocking from the interior
doors of their homes and the affected
door becomes classified as
scp-1879-1 the knocking doesn't stop
until the door is opened at which point
the subject will be greeted by
scp-1879-2 a Caucasian man of
indeterminate age standing around 170
centimeters tall the man will claim to
be a Salesman and immediately try to
pitch a bizarre product to the subject
whose home he's just invaded the SCP
Foundation was first alerted to the
existence of the indoor salesman when
they had intercepted a 9-1-1 call coming
from the home of Mrs Shirley Yates she
had opened the door to her bathroom in
an attempt to get the salesman to stop
knocking and once he was in her home he
refused to leave according to Yates he
kept disappearing in and out of random
doors in her house foundation field
agent Rogers was equipped with a
recording device and sent in to
investigate the case with several other
agents when he arrived at the home he
found Mrs dates inconsolable
scp-1879-2 was still rapidly talking at
her and strangely enough the product he
was holding and trying to sell to her
was a Border Collie puppy as soon as
agent Rogers entered the room the man
shifted his attention away from Mrs
Yates and towards him he then started
trying to sell the puppy to agent Rogers
agent Rogers did not want to purchase
this puppy but he found that the man
spoke so quickly and urgently he
couldn't get a word in edgewise the man
was begging Rogers to take the puppy
practically shoving it in his face
saying that he didn't need any money and
that the only payment he needed would be
some of your time Rogers grew so annoyed
at being talked over and interrupted
that he ordered the other field agents
to apprehend the indoor salesman they
did so but as soon as the agents walked
him out of the front door of the house
he disappeared without a trace the
agents remained in the area to monitor
the situation
scp-1879-2 manifested again and Mrs
yates's home six hours later still
trying to trade the puppy for no money
just a little of her time 12 years to be
precise after hours and hours of being
worn down by this supernaturally pushy
salesman Yates relented and agreed to
take the puppy and immediately
disappeared the indoor salesman then
disappeared himself through the closet
door before he could be apprehended
again at a loss for what to do the
agents administered Class A amnestics to
Mrs yates's family and left the reason
for her disappearance wasn't fully known
until 12 years later in 2015 when she
reappeared in the same spot she
disappeared from having no concept of
how much time had passed the puppy
really had just cost her 12 years of her
life stories like that of Shirley Yates
have popped up all over the state in the
years since from Everett to Walla Walla
and everywhere in between due to the
random nature of
scp-1879 events and the way the indoor
salesman can disappear instantly in and
out of any door in a building the SCP
Foundation has been unable to capture
him the best they've been able to do is
Monitor 9-1-1 calls from across the
state listening for keywords that might
indicate another
scp-1879 infestation when such an event
is reported the foundation deploys
mobile task force Row 4 AKA shoes
salesman this task forces entire purpose
is to minimize the amount of harm the
indoor salesman is able to cause by
intercepting him before he can make a
sale this is a very important task as
evidenced by the story of Mrs Yates
since while the products this salesman
sells might be innocent he doesn't
accept payment in any normal currency
the price he asks for his products are
always bizarre and often deadly if all
someone loses is 12 years of their life
they could be considered to be getting
off easy in one instance the product
being sold was a single red rose in
exchange for the subject's heart once
the deal was sealed the subject dropped
dead on the spot with an autopsy
revealing that his heart and circulatory
system vanished from inside his body in
another the indoor salesman offered 220
bananas and told the subject to Simply
give him some sugar the subject agreed
and all candied Goods in the home
disappeared in a third the indoor
salesman was trying to sell a
thermonuclear Warhead the price of which
was the subject's soul the subject
accepted and at first nothing seemed to
have happened the foundation confiscated
the Warhead and placed it into
non-anomalous containment later that day
the subject went to listen to some music
only to find that two of her vinyl
records had gone missing Lady Soul and
Almighty Fire by world famous soul
singer Aretha Franklin so even though
he's incredibly invasive annoying and
his transactions can be deadly the
indoor salesman still maintains a sense
of humor the fact that the Foundation
can't capture the indoor salesman means
that a lot of questions about him remain
unanswered the biggest by far is why he
does what he does in most
scp-1879 events the indoor salesman
seems frantic and desperate to make a
sale often he will refer to having
quotas and deadlines to meet which
implies some other unseen entity that he
has to answer to these questions remain
unanswered because all attempts to
interrogate the indoor salesmen have
been unsuccessful when he manifests in
the location it's impossible to get him
to stray from a sales pitch and he
disappears as soon as he successfully
sells his Wares however there was one
instance where after an
scp-1879 event took place Foundation
agents were there to witness a rare
interaction between the indoor salesman
and his mysterious employers agent
Rogers and the rest of the shoes
salesmen were called out to a home in
Spokane where rapid knocking had begun
to emanate from the bedroom door
equipped with recording devices Rogers
was able to record the voice of the
indoor salesman coming from inside the
bedroom in the recording the salesman
grumbled to himself about not being able
to meet his quota by tomorrow saying
that if he didn't he'd be stuck in this
world for the next Century he started
knocking again yelling through the door
that he knew they were home he kept
knocking until he was interrupted by the
sound of a phone ringing the indoor
salesman Was Heard picking it up and
Rogers managed to record the
conversation the person calling was
apparently the indoor salesman's boss
who was calling to complain about his
performance only one side of the
conversation was heard but evidently the
indoor salesman's boss wasn't too happy
about receiving two Aretha Franklin
albums as payment instead of an actual
human soul the indoor salesman
apologized for the joke then told his
boss it won't happen again please don't
hurt it I'll meet the quota this time I
swear he hung up grumbling to himself
again I better get to move up to at
least accounting this time I've paid my
dues and then some Rogers finally opened
the door to the apparent disappointment
of the indoor salesman who is hoping to
speak with the home's owner and was
quite annoyed at having another one of
his sales interrupted by MTF row 4.
Rogers tried to ask the indoor salesman
who he'd just been speaking to on the
phone but as usual the salesman started
talking over him now see here let's
think logically he said you know I'm not
going to tell you anything I know you're
not likely to buy what I'm selling so
let's just move on to greener pastures
I'm coming up close to a deadline and
I'm sure you're swamped with making sure
good people don't lose their job so I'll
just be on my way and let you do that
ciao the indoor salesman tried to close
the door but agent Rogers blocked it
with his arm he was tired of this SCP
giving him the runaround and he was
going to keep the indoor salesman here
if it was the last thing he did he
demanded The Entity stay and be
interviewed and other members of the
task force apprehended the salesman
making sure he couldn't leave the room
the indoor salesman now held in place by
several armed men seemed to finally
relent he told Rogers I'm busy so I'll
tell you what I'm going to give you
something no money out of your pocket
and we'll call it even sound good Roger
is just wanting to get this whole thing
over with agreed to those terms three
seconds later every agent on the scene
was dead and the indoor salesman was
able to straighten his tie pick up his
briefcase and walk through the door to
the bathroom when the bodies of agent
Rogers and the rest of the MTF Row 4
were examined by Foundation scientists
the cause of death was found to be in
every case thousands of coins suddenly
appearing in not only their pockets but
also inside their stomachs lungs and
even under their skin later that day the
indoor salesman was reported at a home
in the same neighborhood he was seen
trying to sell The house's owner 80 year
old retiree Alan Johnson a Glock 18
pistol in exchange for his attention as
he had done so many times before the
indoor salesman disappeared through
another door before the foundation was
able to reach the scene and when the SCP
arrived they found Mr Johnson still
alive but now missing his prefrontal
cortex the part of the brain that
controls attention it's likely that
because of the nature of the entity
scp-1879 might be entirely impossible to
contain the foundation might never find
out anything more than what they already
know about the indoor salesman the way
he's able to manifest behind closed
doors or the reason he has to keep
filling quotas for an unseen boss who
apparently doesn't have a very good
sense of humor so if you're ever in
Washington state be careful who you open
your doors to especially if the knocking
you hear is coming from inside your
house
in a remote part of Russia a mysterious
disease outbreak was tearing through a
tiny farming village with terrifying
side effects there was no cure no clue
to where it came from and worst of all
the disease's terrifying impact didn't
end with death no it was after those
carrying the disease died that the real
Horrors started after an agonizing fever
that leaves the victims writhing in pain
they quickly succumbed to the disease
only to rise from their graves to wreak
havoc on the living the virus continues
to spread until the corpses outnumber
those trying to hide from them as the
world spirals into almost certain ruins
it sounds like the plot of a zombie
movie but for the SCP Foundation this is
anything but fiction and the terror that
unfolded in that little Siberian town is
the first recorded encounter with
scp-610 also known as the flesh that
hates first livestock began to vanish
from farms after wild animals were
suspected but no suspects could be found
and no mutilated remains turned up the
animals weren't being stolen and they
weren't being eaten so what happened to
them with no more animals Left to Lose
the farmers themselves then began to
disappear but the authorities refused to
take the missing persons cases seriously
the missing Farmers families would
contact the police make a report and
then the whole thing was forgotten it
was written off just as another unsolved
disappearance which wasn't uncommon in
the wild and unforgiving region then the
police themselves began to disappear the
families of the missing Farmers would
sometimes report strange sounds from the
surrounding Woods describing moans and
inhuman screeches of pain
one young boy reported seeing a cow with
what he described as tentacles lurking
around the edge of the trees Regional
Police were dispatched to the location
in order to investigate and report back
on their findings within 24 hours but
the units sent to the area didn't report
back and were never heard from again
upon learning of the reports the Russian
government grew increasingly concerned
fearing domestic Insurgency or foreign
Espionage of some kind could be at play
they sent a small team of special agents
to the area and one by one those agents
disappeared just like the others before
them it seemed no one who went into the
village after the disappearances started
ever came out again they had all simply
vanished desperate for answers the
Russian government contacted the only
people in the world who could help the
SCP Foundation what the foundation found
over the course of their investigation
would shock and unnerve them going
beyond anything they had previously
discovered before the investigation
officially began the affected area was
sealed off by the Russian government not
knowing if it would be safe to send
researchers into the containment
perimeter the foundation set up a small
camera mounted unit nicknamed Herbie to
capture footage of whatever remained of
the village the images captured by
Herbie revealed what exactly had become
of the people in this doomed Village and
the true nightmarish nature of scp-610
scp-610 is a cutter class entity meaning
it's an anomaly that's exceedingly
difficult to contain consistently or
reliably with containment procedures
often being extensive and complex 610 is
a highly contagious skin disease that
initially manifests like an ordinary
allergic reaction with symptoms
including increased sensitivity itching
and a rash but within just three hours
of those initial symptoms appearing the
rash starts to turn into masses of Scar
Tissue on the chest and arms these
masses spread over the legs and back of
the victim and completely consume them
in thick rubbery flesh within five hours
once they're covered the victim will
cease all vital functions unfortunately
for them and doubly so for those around
them they do not stay Dead about three
minutes after expiring the victim's
vitals will restart at a heightened rate
and the masses of Flesh encasing their
body will begin to move and multiply
mutating them into a form beyond
anything resembling the human they once
were the specific type of mutation
varies from case to case but as included
the head becoming massive in bulbous the
growth of extra limbs and an especially
gruesome cases the victim's body
splitting apart to allow extra tendrils
of Flesh to sprout from the open wound
occasionally an infected person will
stop moving and become rooted to the
ground in a set location once it is
settled their flesh will spread itself
across the ground encasing all nearby
objects in flaps of scar tissue the
infected that maintain their Mobility
are highly aggressive even violent and
will attempt to infect any living thing
that comes into their line of sight the
disease does not only infect humans and
can take over any living organism within
a matter of hours due to the highly
contagious and dangerous nature of the
disease safe observation of infected
specimens and areas is only possible
with drones and mounted cameras this
brings us back to Herbie the first such
mounted camera to record footage of the
infected area Herbie was deployed to an
infection site also known as site a
without any damage it remained at the
outside perimeter of the village for two
hours observing several infected humans
and fire damage to many of the homes
before following an infected into an
intact house Herbie's camera feed
captured the infected person entering
the house and sitting down at the table
inside there were several other infected
humans in the house and one unidentified
infected creature that remained immobile
under the table after viciously
assaulting one of the other infected
humans the infected returned to the
table and began to lay out plates on top
of it pieces of its flesh began to
wriggle and tear away from its body
before settling onto each plate once the
plates were filled the infected sitting
at the table began to grab at the Flesh
and crush it into their mouths in a
perverse imitation of a normal mealtime
Gathering after capturing this stomach
churning display Herbie left the house
and continued to explore the village the
recorded footage of a large stack of
bodies that seemed to be made up of both
Russian military and civilians with an
infected sitting on top as Herbie
maneuvered towards the remains of the
Town Hall an infected grabbed the Rover
off the ground Herbie's camera was able
to capture the face of the infected that
grabbed the Rover the face was that of a
young girl around 10 years old strangely
intact to top a large distorted body the
final moments of Herbie's camera feed
captured the infected girl's face
bursting open revealing tendrils of
Flesh that pulled Herbie into the gaping
Maw
then the feed cut to Black Herbie was
regarded as lost but the video feed
briefly resumed five hours later showing
the camera covered with an unidentified
slime after this the video feed was cut
for good and Herbie abandoned Insight a
the foundation has sent several manned
Expeditions into side a where many
Expedition forces have fallen victim to
the infected several operatives were
also lost in an earthquake that revealed
a network of underground tunnels a
manned Expedition into these tunnels was
attempted and the video feed that was
captured by the researchers on the
expedition was deeply disturbing there
were images of an abandoned church
filled with infected and a massive
uninfected or partially infected human
captives
the final moments of the video feed from
this Expedition captured several
operatives being murdered by an infected
human wielding a farming Scythe
indicating that the infected are capable
of using simple Weaponry in addition to
Brute Force the use of this weapon
paired with the presence of captives in
the underground tunnels paints a
terrifying picture of the kind of
organization the infected are capable of
no more manned Expeditions have been
attempted or if they have they have been
highly classified ordinarily once a new
SCP is discovered it is placed in
containment at the foundation with
special procedures in place so that it
can be studied or even neutralized in
the rare occasions where it's deemed
necessary when it comes to scp-610
though containment might just be
impossible it simply covers too much
area and is too dangerous to expose to
human researchers instead all infected
areas have been isolated with the
permission of the Russian government
there is an official perimeter
established around these areas and any
civilians that approach them are told to
leave under the pretense of ongoing
military operations for once a
top-secret military project is the more
innocent answer armed guards are placed
at the perimeter of every infected area
and any living thing with symptoms of
scp-610 spotted near the perimeter is to
be immobilized killed and burned from as
far away as possible any living thing
that comes in contact with scp-610
whether a soldier a scientist or a
civilian is immediately terminated and
their remains destroyed if someone comes
within three meters of an infected
organism they will be quarantined and
remotely examined to determine if they
have been infected while the spread of
scp-610 can be airborne it has been
determined to be far less contagious
when spread through air particles as
opposed to physical contact the
infection sites remain active to this
day like modern day leper colonies
though they are isolated from the
general population and the military is
doing everything in their power to
contain the infected SCP 610 is still
very much alive it is rare for an entity
to exist that the foundation cannot
truly contain but can only try to guard
against and that makes this infection
all the more terrifying who knows how
much it has mutated over the years
growing spreading hungry for new hosts
there is still so much that the
foundation does not know about the flesh
that hates such as how it works what it
can do or even where it came from since
the origin of the first infection is
still at this point entirely unknown it
has shown itself to be capable of
learning planning and protecting itself
so who is to say that it couldn't figure
out a way to escape from its isolated
area it is so highly contagious and
spreads so quickly that just one tiny
infected rabbit and one inattentive
soldier could be enough for scp-610 to
reach the general population if it did
its violent destructive nature and
hatred for all life would mean that
everything not just the people but
animals plants and the world itself
could be at risk and no one is ready for
this kind of infection a disease that
turns the human body against itself
turns our skin into a weapon and a tomb
stripping away identity humanity and
everything that isn't made of the same
hateful flesh so let's hope that the
perimeter holds and the next time you
feel a little itchy try not to think
about what might happen next addiction
it takes many forms and wears many faces
like a demon walking Among Us it takes
over your life crawling in and changing
you from the inside out breaking and
addiction is hard but oftentimes not
giving it up is much harder that was a
difficult lesson to learn for three
people Joey Walker Dolly McGregor and
Paul Ables these three had never met one
another and now they never will but each
one of them had two things in common
first was that each had an addiction
they felt like they couldn't shake and
second was that they each had a run-in
with
scp-66 Joey Walker was at the end of his
rope when he encountered it everyone has
bad days but for Joey every day for the
last 15 years has been a bad day he was
pushing 40 with nothing to show for it
except credit card debt a scraggly beard
and a beat up old Mustang but booze had
always been there for him no matter how
bad things got he could always count on
a glass full of comfort at the end of
the day but to paraphrase a quote by
Stephen King sometimes when a man takes
a drink the drink takes the man and Joey
Walker had been long since taken he was
a transient worker doing jobs wherever
jobs needed doing but he never expected
that he would end up all the way to
Tibet working construction not that he
was complaining I'm sure it was cold but
there was plenty of Tibetan Chang to
enjoy it was a drink so good that
Legends even say that yetis would raid
villages in the mountains just to get a
little taste Joey had taken a liking to
the Chang and it was what he had been
drinking when he crashed his car up in
the mountains leaving him stranded in
the snow Joey had survived the crash
itself but he knew he wouldn't last long
in the cold he needed shelter that's why
he felt like he could hardly believe his
luck when he first saw the yurt a kind
of traditional Tibetan tent made from
animal skins Joey had never seen
anything quite like it but any Refuge
from the storm would do he pushed
forward through the snow and climbed
inside but the inside of the yurt was
nothing like the outside in fact it
seemed like an exact replica of his
favorite sports bar back in Atlantic
City it was warm there was all the old
memorabilia on the walls and every
screen was showing the Saints wiping the
floor with the Colts in the 2010 Super
Bowl Joey didn't even question it he
just smiled and approached the bar he
even recognized the bartender Malcolm a
good old friend of his Malcolm smiled
back at him but there was something
oddly menacing in his grin welcome back
he said I thought you'd hauled your
sorry keister off to Tibet guess you
gave up on that too just like everything
else
well except Malcolm pushed a glass of
beer towards him across the bar and
glared Joey didn't understand why
Malcolm was being so aggressive but he
didn't question that either he grabbed
the glass and drank it up guzzling it
down before slamming The Empty Glass
down on the bar Malcolm kept the drinks
coming round after round and Joey kept
knocking them back he didn't notice when
the TV screens turned to static he
didn't notice when the other patrons at
the bar began to Jitter in twitch
turning little by little into something
less than human he didn't even notice
when Malcolm's face started melting off
his skull as long as he kept pouring
before it could even really understand
what was happening to him Joey Walker
was dead his living knees had given out
on him his corpse would later be found
Frozen on the Tibetan Mountainside just
30 feet away from his crash car the
coroner's report would list his cause of
death as accidental but this was no
accident he'd Fallen victim to scp-66 an
anomalous yurt known to some as the
spirit house the being he'd call Malcolm
is known to the foundation as
scp-66-1 and Joey had failed its
challenge sadly for our inebriated
friend the penalty for failure is death
next on our list of human tragedies
comes Dolly McGregor a 62 year old woman
from Anaheim California dolly was never
averse to the drink but she knew how to
enjoy her Mojitos in moderation you
rarely get to 62 if you don't and Dolly
could tell people with pride that she
had two children and six grandchildren
whom she didn't see nearly often enough
for her liking she also had over 100 in
gambling debt owed to a number of
casinos on the Vegas Strip ever since
her husband Albert had passed away
several years prior shooting craps
playing Blackjack and willing away the
hours in front of the slot machines had
been a welcome change from loneliness
but in Vegas fortunes can change in an
instant Dolly had gone from being on a
hot winning streak to losing everything
the casinos extended her lines of credit
until she was gambling with money she'd
never be able to pay back but that
didn't stop her she'd been selling off
everything even remortgaging the house
that Albert had built with his own two
hands to try and keep up with her
ballooning deaths still it wasn't enough
but she couldn't stop either it wasn't
even that she felt good about it anymore
it was just that she only ever felt
normal among the flashing lights of slot
machines and the clatter of dice she
needed to get away as far away as
possible she heard about people reaching
spiritual enlightenment in Tibet they
discover God or gods or sometimes just a
sense of inner peace whatever it was you
needed to find it and get this demon off
her back so she took the last of her
savings and flew off to devat to clear
her head she didn't know if there were
any casinos in lhasa but if there were
her money would surely be no good there
it was exactly what she needed but Tibet
wasn't the promised land she thought it
would be wherever Dolly went there she
was with the same vices and demons
chasing her the first night she spent in
lhasa she used the hotel Wi-Fi to
download an online poker app on her
phone this culminated in another couple
thousand dollars lost and a panic attack
that caused Dolly to throw her phone
into her toilet before wandering off
into the Wilderness she just needed to
get away but time and space got away
from her and eventually she was
knee-deep in snow where had she come
from where could she go it quickly
dawned on her that if she didn't find
some kind of shelter soon she'd be done
for but all she could do was keep
walking that's when she happened upon
scp-66 the yurt was like an oasis on the
barren Mountainside she didn't expect
Comfort inside but it could at least
provide her some shelter until the Staff
back at the hotel noticed she was gone
then they'd come and save her right
right but when she passed through the
yak leather flap into the Earth Dolly
wasn't in an ancient tent in the Tibetan
Wilderness she was on a casino floor
there was a big beautiful roulette table
before her attended to by a grinning
well-dressed coupier they were flanked
by an army of slot machines and all the
pleasing familiar sounds of cheerful
gambling rang out through the air she
approached the table and the croupier
shook his head in what seemed like
disappointment ah back again a dolly he
said with a sigh of course I should have
expected it after all what else do you
have in in that empty little life of
yours and without all this you'd be
nothing right nothing at all since
Albert died and the kids want nothing to
do with you we're all you've got so
Dolly what'll be red or black are you
feeling lucky his words wounded Dolly
but that wouldn't stop her she grabbed
her chips and put them all on red one
last spin couldn't hurt what did she
have to lose she blinked and she wasn't
sitting at the table anymore she was
upright but she wasn't standing her
wrists and ankles were bound to
something to a wheel a giant roulette
wheel like it was some kind of medieval
torture device the croupier was standing
across from her while something that
used to be a croupier his face was
flickering in and out sometimes it was
humans sometimes it was a mass of eyes
and teeth more demons were sitting all
at the slot machines behind him pulling
levers made from human bones good choice
Dolly the croupier said red suits you he
reached out and gave the wheel a spin
dolly was lost in an overwhelming
pulsing Cascade of Lights colors and
sounds the horrific tinny noises of slot
machines and the laughter of the Demonic
croupier she was lost in panic and
Terror as she just kept spinning and
spinning and spinning when her body was
eventually found her muscles were in the
advanced stages of atrophy as though she
hadn't been moving for years her brain
was rotted and the cause of death was
determined as sudden cardiac arrest
after an extended period of sleep
deprivation and malnutrition Dali's
family would never really know what
happened to her the SCP Foundation has
learned a lot about scp-666 after
containing it in site-73 its anomalous
of facts namely Vivid complex and
potentially fatal hallucinatory
experiences only affect those with some
kind of addiction or dependency to
anyone else entering the yurt it's just
a normal tent but any addicts who enter
will fall under its spell and are
generally transported back to the place
where their addiction was at its
strongest there they'll encounter
scp-66-1 an entity that takes the form
of a figure from the subject's life
normally one heavily involved in
facilitating their addiction any kind of
addiction seems to trigger it alcohol
drugs gambling pornography Foods
self-destructive Behavior even video
games
scp-66 kills its victims with a twisted
mockery of the very thing that they were
dependent on in life it was only with
Paul Ables that the foundation started
discovering the other side of the coin
by almost all accounts Paul is a worse
person than anyone on this list he got
addicted to hard drugs early on in life
and took up a life of violent crime to
support his habit he murdered two people
during a liquor store robbery before
being convicted and sentenced to death
he'd then been picked up as a d-class by
the SCP Foundation and selected as a
test subject for scp-66 due to his
history of drug abuse the foundation
expected to be adding his body to the
incineration pile sometime soon none of
the researchers working on the case
predicted what actually ended up
happening Paul was forced to enter the
yurt not long after he found himself
standing in a place he'd done everything
to try to forget the dark graffiti
stained alley Where he'd been sold his
first hit this was the place the place
that destroyed his life every bad
decision he'd ever made could be traced
back to here and specifically to one man
Frank Frank was his first dealer and now
here he was standing right across from
him once more Frank was grinning like a
demon come on Polly he said he got it
trash we both know what you're gonna do
don't you feel it the itch come on one
more hit Polly that's all you need to
feel better it's time to take your
medicine Frank or this thing pretending
to be frank was right he did feel the
itch he did want it maybe he was no
better than this he began to reach out
towards Frank but then he abruptly
pulled his hand back Frank's eyes widen
and genuine surprise as Paul replied I'm
sorry that's not me anymore
scp-66-1 gave a smile and said maybe it
isn't Polly maybe it isn't when Paul
Ables was removed from the scp-66 yard
by one of the attending guards the
foundation researchers discovered
something amazing Paul was very much
alive and more incredibly he didn't feel
the Cravings anymore his addiction was
gone and further tests showed that Paul
wasn't a one-off event in fact anyone
who denies the temptation of scp-66 will
see their addictions miraculously
disappear when they finally only leave
after this it became clear to the
foundation that scp-66 isn't just a way
to punish addicts it's a kind of test
those who want to change who are willing
to truly confront their demons and
resist the pull of Temptation are
rewarded with the one thing they want
most in their life freedom from their
addiction
scp-66 can be your doom or your
salvation and like most things in life
you get what you give in almost all
respects Kevin O'Reilly is your average
50-something Irish man he lives in
County Cork with his wife Martha where
he spends his day working at a local
accountancy firm and during his free
evenings he likes to take quiet walks
through the nearby Woods there is only
one remarkable thing that can be said
about Kevin he was the second human ever
to encounter an example of
scp-3199 a dangerous ketter class
anomaly that has the power to knock
Humanity off the top of the food chain
if left unchecked we know what you're
thinking what about the first human
don't worry we'll get to him but we can
assure you he's anything but
unremarkable back to Kevin he was
enjoying one of his nightly walks when
he heard a horrible shrieking sound in
the distance it sounded like a woman was
being murdered and just hearing it
chilled poor Kevin to his core his first
instinct was to run to the woman's Aid
and do whatever he could but there was a
lurking anxiety under the surface the
echoing memory of an old childhood
Legend the Banshee a monstrous ghostly
woman of Irish folklore whose blood
curdling screams always foretell death
but those were all just stories surely
Grim Omens to stop children from
straying too far from the path Kevin
took his first Brave step in the
direction of that awful screaming
repeating the quiet Mantra of there's no
such thing as monsters to himself again
and again if only he knew just how wrong
he was he ran deeper into the forest
following the awful sounds whoever this
woman was she certainly had some pipes
on her the screaming had been going on
for minutes on end now and it didn't
seem to show any signs of subsiding the
sky above had darkened from everything
to full on night by the time Kevin
reached the source of the screaming
Kevin found himself in a clearing in the
forest but in all his years of walking
down here he'd never seen it before
there was a ramshackle old Cottage
rotten with age and damp and next to it
a rusty old Hut made from corrugated
iron like a kind of oversized Chicken
Coop from the tinny echoing quality of
the screams he knew that they were
coming from inside the hot was a woman
being held captive here Kevin was a
smart man he approached the tin Hut
quietly not saying a word if this woman
had indeed been captured and was now
being held against her well it wouldn't
help the situation to potentially alert
her captor to his presence this quick
thinking is the reason that Kevin
O'Reilly is still alive today because
when he arrived outside the tin Hut and
peered in through the window what he saw
inside was not a woman in fact it wasn't
even human the Beast that Kevin saw
inside the hut was nothing short of a
crime against nature a Twisted
Abomination that was only vaguely
humanoid its bloated fleshy body dripped
with some kind of viscous fluid and it
looked more like a plucked rotten
chicken than a person the creature was
shrieking and wailing its huge body
convulsing in the coop it was making a
gurgling gagging noise like something
was strangling it Kevin felt like he was
going to be attack but the monster beat
him to it it doubled over its wretched
lipless mouth stretched open to freakish
proportions and started to vomit
something out it was a gray leathery
mask covered in dark red blood that soon
flopped out onto the ground among a
number of other masses that looked just
like it the creature then gave one final
whale and spewed out a red stream of
blood and bile onto the masses that's
when Kevin realized what he was looking
at eggs a pile of big unnatural eggs the
foul-smelling vial that the creature had
just vomited up had no effect on the
eggs but it seemed to burn and corrode
the surrounding environment it hissed
against the metal as thin wisps of steam
Rose from The Scorch marks Kevin was
horrified but also entranced by the
bizarre sight until the creature stood
back up and began to turn towards him
Kevin didn't let his morbid curiosity
get the better of him he turned and
sprinted out of the forest knowing that
if he lingered for even a second longer
he wouldn't return home alive he ran and
ran and finally heard the Wailing Fade
Into the distance behind him this was
the first ever outside brush with a
specimen of
scp-3199 also known as humans refuted
sadly it would be far from the last and
would remain one of the rare few that
wasn't deadly when Kevin got back to
town he immediately told everyone what
he saw there's a monster in the woods
and it's breeding he even told the local
newspaper which printed the headline be
cited in local Forest it was enough to
get the SCP foundation's attention field
agents were sent into the town proper to
suppress the information leaking about
the creature and gather any additional
information they needed to assess
whether they were dealing with a real
anomaly here or just another crank
straight away though the agents could
tell from Kevin's demeanor that he had
seen something truly awful he was given
amnestics and mobile task force Omega 19
were dispatched to secure and contain
the creatures that Kevin had seen they
had 12 well-armed Personnel trained and
prepared to deal with anything or so
they thought they were led by Corporal
Duncan a seasoned MTF operative and they
used state-of-the-art night vision
technology to gain a tactical advantage
in the dead of night all they had to
work on though was the visual
description provided by Mr O'Reilly it
didn't take long for them to find the
same clearing out in the woods there was
the rotten old Cottage in the metal Coop
just like Kevin had described two
younger MTF members private mcloyd and
private Langley were eager to take the
lead and prove themselves as they
explored the dilapidated nightmare of a
house once inside they heard strange
noises what they assumed must have been
footsteps coming from deeper in the
they crept further in and that's when
private mcloyd first noticed it the
shape of a large pale bulbous figure at
the end of a long hallway shivering
slightly in the cold compared to some of
the hardened Killers he had heard about
in combat training this creature looked
like a piece of cake this half man half
chicken it was almost a walking joke he
leveled his weapon and grinned as he
approached the creature but private
mcloyd had made a fatal mistake he
underestimated his enemy in a later
Foundation debriefing interview Corporal
Duncan would Report with a dull horror
what he saw happen to private mcloyd
that terrible day he'd never seen a
smile fade from someone's face so fast
as the creature turned shrieked and
sprinted down the hallway towards
private mcloyd the poor private barely
even had time to raise his gun his hands
quivering with panic though even if
mcloyd had been quicker on the draw it
probably wouldn't have saved him him as
the Beast approached it spewed its foul
stinking red bile onto mcloyd's face it
was a sudden burning sensation so
powerful that he passed out in an
instant his lower face dripping off of
his own skull he was dead in mere
moments then the Beast lept forward and
began attacking private Langley biting
and stinging and spewing more of its
deadly acidic liquid by the time it was
done there was barely any of Langley
left to retrieve from the house the 10
surviving task force members opened fire
on the creature but along with being
surprisingly fast it could also
apparently take quite a licking even
when Corporal Duncan managed a direct
hit on the creature's chest blowing a
portion of it away the monster just let
out the most awful scream and continued
fighting Corporal Duncan admits that to
this day that scream and the Moonlight
shining through the hole in the
creature's chest continued to haunt him
when the monster was finally subdued
they were able to to take it back to the
nearby Evac Chopper and begin the
journey to the nearest containment
facility but things took another
terrible turn during that fateful flight
the creature's body began to convulse
before vomiting up a pair of large
leathery eggs without a moment's
hesitation the eggs began to bulge and
tear open and a pair of rapidly growing
scp-3199 instances crawled out attacking
the mobile task force members huddled
together in the cramped confines of the
helicopter once the second Onslaught was
over only four of the remaining 10
members of personnel were left alive the
foundation had discovered a formidable
new foe the specimens were brought back
to site 114 and placed in a modified
version of the standard ketter class
containment chamber it was fitted with
acid resistant steel walls and a series
of transparent resin blocks to store the
specimens inside for constant
observation but the creatures weren't
given cutter class for nothing Escape
attempts are frequent and whenever they
happen the number of creatures in
containment increases the most
frightening detail of scp-3199 is the
fact that it's impossible to reduce the
number of them in existence each
creature has a unique stomach-like organ
inside its body which holds an egg in
reserve while it's possible to destroy
one of the creatures the eggs have
proven to be almost indestructible as a
result when one of them dies the egg
within attaches and immediately grows
into a replacement and if the creatures
are ever allowed to roam free they begin
laying eggs in any unoccupied space they
can find causing their numbers to grow
in theory if left unchecked they could
supplant the human race with their own
species in hardly any time at all the
only solution that the foundation has
found is submerging the creature's in
sedative laced water as the beasts seem
to inherent register water-filled areas
as occupied space and therefore do not
begin laying eggs while submerged but
even the foundation's most optimistic
Minds still admit this is only a
temporary solution but where did these
awful creatures come from after the
chaos of the first mission the
foundation had dispatched an additional
mobile task force surface Team Delta
029e to perform a Second Sweep of the
house and figure out what had been going
on during the two decades of preceding
silence inside the team managed to
collect a number of strange objects to
bring back as evidence of the peculiar
activities that had taken place there
among these were a number of chicken
carcasses that bore evidence of surgical
dissection a pair of chicken feather
quills and an A5 hardcover notebook
labeled New Breed Manifesto its writer
is believed to be deceased most likely
as a result of scp-3199 but the final
note scrawled inside the book and date
1973 provides some insight into what had
occurred inside that dilapidated Shack
in Ireland it reads if eating this then
lucky
400 000 hours from now and it will be
warm and wet and warm and the wonderful
versatility Versa versatility of
inferior Schumann DNA will birth a
better error a stronger error one wealth
foods and water will be nothing but
things of the past as we make and make
and make more until I really haven't
watched time
that's why I envy you so so much you'll
have all the time you need time will be
a thing of all the time will be on and
on and death could be life life new
things to live new life will be part of
life from now on these are the last
words of the deranged mad scientist who
created
scp-3199 perhaps under the demented
belief that somehow they would make the
world a better place personally we don't
think
scp-3199 have any interest in improving
the world but whether we like it or not
their insane Creator is right about one
thing there are problem now agent Carla
Mendoza was one of the best field agents
that site 41 had ever seen she was
professional cool under pressure and
when the situation demanded it she could
be a straight-up badass during a chaos
Insurgency raid on the site she'd single
handedly killed four different
insurgents the last one with her bare
hands during containment breaches she'd
always be the first one charging Into
The Fray her foundation standard issue
Beretta drawn and ready to fire agent
Mendoza was so devoted to the job that
she took up the site director's offer to
start living on site so she could always
be there to help if an emergency
situation unfolded after all when it all
hits the fan you want someone as utterly
unshakable as agent Mendoza on your side
the job had thrown the worst of the
worst at her and she'd never even
flinched so surely nothing could scare
agent Mendoza right after a long day of
kicking ass taking names and filling in
the properly mandated amount of SCP
Foundation debriefing paperwork agent
Mendoza retired to her site-41 quarters
she felt exhausted and sweaty so before
heading to bed to watch some wonderful
SCP explained videos on her phone how
kind she decided to take a a quick
shower the last thing she expected was
for this particular shower to become
well let's say hitchcockian the water
was running hot and clean filling the
air with steam agent Mendoza was
lathering up her hair when she first
heard the noise heavy wheezing breaths
coming from just behind the shower
curtain the second she heard it agent
Mendoza felt a kind of brutal crushing
anxiety that she'd never experienced
before like a hand was reaching into her
chest and squeezing her heart the
self-defense training that had been
encoded into her muscle memory over
years of working at the foundation
kicked into effect in a blind panic she
struck out at the shower curtain causing
it to sway outwards and land directly on
the face of Mendoza's wheezing voyeur
who or whatever it was it was standing
right there less than a meter away from
the shower the wheezing carved into
Mendoza's ears like a butcher's knife
what an awful monstrous sound and
despite the fact that the shower curtain
obscured its face she could still
somehow see it the way a defenseless
animal can sense an approaching Predator
without ever locking eyes on it and just
somehow know that it's too late for them
to escape now every training session
every achievement every piece of battle
hardening experience it all evaporated
in the presence of that thing Mendoza
was so terrified she might as well have
been a child the monster just stood
there beyond the curtain its raw fleshy
face parted into a freakishly wide
yellow-toothed grin she didn't know how
but on some deep Primal level she was
aware that if this thing got its hands
on her something horrific Beyond
description would happen to her she was
too terrified to even move a muscle in
its presence she remained like that
standing in the shower and sobbing
quietly for the next three solid hours
until the creature finally disappeared
when her colleagues found her she'd
experienced moderate scalding wounds
from the hot water of the shower it took
several hours for agent Mendoza to
compose herself enough to share her
story a couple days later Tim Ellis a
junior level filing clerk was found
trapped in a site-41 Supply Closet he'd
urinated in his foundation issued slacks
and was in a state of borderline
Catatonia when his superiors asked him
why he'd been spending two hours in a
Supply Closet on company time he
reported that it was because a monster
had appeared outside the door when he
was searching for a replacement stapler
despite never actually opening the door
to see what was outside or call for help
Mr Ellis said that he felt as though he
would have had a heart attack if he
actually opened that accursed door he
was able to provide a clear description
of the monster he said it was tall and
emaciated with reddish brown skin that
made it seem almost burnt or rotten
while it stood there and waited beyond
the supply closet door it have let out
the most awful wheezing noise like an
old rusty iron lung but the image that
Ellis seemed most fixated on was the
monster's face or lack thereof just a
huge grinning mouth that covered up its
entire head stocked with an arsenal of
massive yellow teeth Ellis was visibly
shivering as he talked about it two
incidents are an unpleasant coincidence
but three are a bona fide pattern and it
didn't take long for more sightings of
this strange new anomaly dubbed scp-303
or the doorman to pop up across the site
it earned that name by always appearing
behind some kind of doorway or at least
a movable divider in the case of agent
Mendoza's shower curtain whenever it
appeared outside a doorway nearby
Foundation Personnel would report being
struck with a sudden paralyzing Terror
that made engaging with the creature
impossible attempts to call for help
were also often stifled as the very
presence of the the doorman causes
disruptions to electrical equipment
whenever the doorman manifests in your
proximity it's safe to say that it'll be
commanding your absolute undivided
attention this was a particularly
frightening case for the SCP Foundation
because it was one of the few anomalies
bringing the fight directly to them most
sentient anomalous beings would do
anything to avoid getting captured by
the SCP Foundation and contained in one
of their high security sites full of
experienced researchers and
state-of-the-art Equipment designed
specifically to neutralize their effects
the doorman however just seemed to take
this as a challenge turning even the
most hardcore Personnel on the site into
gibbering wrecks with its mere presence
but the doorman was just getting started
agent Henderson had a frightening
encounter in the break room he was
pulling a long shift and just wanted to
grab some coffee creamer from the
cabinet however as he approached the
cabinet he heard The Telltale wheezing
in that terrible overwhelming Terror set
in once more the doorman was sitting
inside the cabinet in a fetal position
he just knew it could this thing really
appear just anywhere as it pleased and
keep people in or out until it decided
to dematerialize and torment somebody
else when the creature finally
dematerialized and the cabinet was
examined the coffee creamer was found to
be missing leaving agent Henderson
distraught this was the first recorded
instance of the doorman stealing a
physical item but it would be far from
the last Henderson wondered whether the
creature that had just humiliated him
was sitting somewhere else now sipping
from a warm cup of joe with its big
freakish mouth and laughing at him but a
few incidents after this things would
become considerably more serious the
doorman was about to take its first life
well it isn't really that simple if you
want to get into the semantics of the
thing when the body of Dr Barker was
found inside the second floor storage
room after a spree of scp-303 incidents
the question was naturally posed as to
whether the doorman had gotten more
dangerous and finally directly attacked
one of its victims not quite there had
only been one way in and out of the
storage room a secure decompression
chamber and the doorman had appeared
inside this chamber while Dr Barker was
in the storage room effectively trapping
him inside with the sheer Terror it
causes and its victims it was trapped in
the room for a grand total of five days
at which point he finally died of
dehydration and the doorman demanifested
shortly afterward the staff of site 41
scaled up their countermeasure efforts
hoping to discover more about and
perhaps even trap and contain the
infamous doorman Dr Burroughs researcher
Matthews four members of security
personnel and four d-class operatives
formed a kind of Strike Team ready for
quick dispatches whenever the doorman
happened to manifest it wasn't long
before for the creature appeared in a
room on the first floor but the team
quickly intercepted its location ready
and eager to gather more data on the
mysterious being that had been
terrorizing them all for weeks Dr
Burroughs ordered one of the d-classes
to open the door and look inside but the
d-class refused out of fear the doctor
told him that if he didn't open the door
he'd be transferred to scp-682 duty the
d-class frantically shook his head and
said I'd rather take my chances with the
reptile than go in there the doctor was
getting frustrated he told the d-class
that if he didn't open the door
immediately he'd be terminated right
there on the spot the d-class still
refused saying that he'd take death over
what the doorman would do to him if he
stepped inside without hesitation Dr
Burrows ordered one of the security
officers to shoot the d-class then and
there the shot was fired the d-class was
terminated Dr Burroughs then ordered a
female d-class who just witnessed this
callous execution to open the door or
the same abrupt death would befall her
she still refused then began to describe
the awful things she believed the
doorman would do to her if she went
inside researcher Matthews was visibly
shaken by the description Dr Burroughs
decided not to terminate this d-class
immediately he instead wanted to see
just how much pressure the doorman's
anomalous fear-based resistance
mechanisms could take another d-class
was given a combat knife and also given
the order to cut the female d-class with
it every time she refused and ordered to
go inside after two hours of repeated
asking from Dr Burrows the female
d-class dropped dead from blood loss at
no point did she ever attempt to open
the door it seemed that in all the cases
for those in the thrall of the doorman's
anomalous effects death is a truly
preferable alternative to ever facing it
head-on it's worth mentioning that these
tests were conducted back in the 1970s
before the formation of the foundation's
Ethics Committee which explains why
their methods feel a little needlessly
cruel since then the door man has fully
commandeered the second floor storage
room the same one where it caused Dr
Barker's death it only leaves the room
to steal more items from around the site
these items have included a cryo tube
three sets of standard foundation
surgical equipment two d-class research
cadavers one gasoline-powered generator
a variety of chemicals from the chemical
storage areas and of course poor agent
Henderson's can of powdered coffee
creamer the reason for the doorman
taking an interest in these particular
items remains unknown but we can only
assume that nothing good can come of it
and there you have it folks the strange
frightening and eerily inconclusive tale
of the doorman all we can really say is
that we're awfully glad he's fixated on
bothering site-41 because who knows what
would happen if he widened his net to
the rest of us thankfully we won't need
to think about that oh that's odd can
you hear that I thought I was imagining
it so come to think of it I can't help
but feel a little uneasy right now do
you ever get that feeling that you're
being watched wait the door there's
something behind the door can you feel
it can you feel its red flesh and rotten
teeth pressing up against it breathing
waiting Can you feel it staring at you
without eyes looking deep into your very
Soul well that's good but just stay
cautious okay after all life has many
doors head boy and you never know who or
what will be waiting for you behind the
next one it was an old factory in the
middle of nowhere long abandoned but
still standing in the past it I've been
filled with workers but now nothing ran
through it besides the occasional
Wildlife one July night in 1949 though
four teenagers decided it would be a
good place to explore the entrance to
the factory was a large old-fashioned
looking wooden door that was locked
tightly shot the teens looked around for
another way in but couldn't find one
what they did find though was an old
iron lock box after some some effort
they managed to get the Box open and
found a ring of 12 old rusted steel Keys
sitting inside with these old Keys open
the wooden door would they find
something inside that would make their
night of breaking and entering worth it
if only they knew that by unlocking the
door all they would find was true horror
because they had just found
scp-004 better known as the 12 keys and
the door not long after the local
sheriff received a call from three of
the panic teens they explained that
while trying to get into the factory one
of their friends had gone missing the
local authorities were quickly deployed
taking the three teens into custody and
beginning a full search of the factory
grounds the searching Sheriff's
Department officers did eventually
manage to find a clue as to what
happened to the missing team but it
wasn't a good sign it was their severed
hand and even more disturbing is that it
wasn't discovered out outside the
factory no it was found over eight
kilometers away soon other body parts
were also found some as far as 32
kilometers away but how could the parts
of the Dead teenager's body have been
scattered so quickly and so far from
each other when the surviving teens were
interrogated they all repeated the same
wild story The now dead teen had taken
one of the keys out of the old box they
had found and used it to unlock the
strange old-fashioned wooden door that
led into the factory they opened the
door and stepped inside and the moment
they did they were immediately torn into
pieces that suddenly vanished these were
no ordinary keys and this was no
ordinary door it was clear this was a
job for the SCP Foundation an SCP agent
was deployed to the site to begin
investigating this anomaly after getting
the keys from local authorities the
agent brought in a group of 12 decline
us Personnel to test them one for each
key and it soon became clear that there
was one effect that was common 10 of the
keys seemed to cause an effect that was
completely unsurvivable upon trying the
key in the door the test subject was
immediately torn apart just like the
unfortunate teenager while one key
caused the body parts to be scattered in
the immediate vicinity all the others
seemed to vanish Into Thin Air but it
was the other two keys that proved to be
of even greater interest to the
foundation unlike with all the other
tests the d-class using the key
designated
scp-004-7 was able to enter the door and
return completely unharmed but the
d-class using
scp-004-12 was a different story
physically he returned unharmed but he
seemed barely able to stagger out of the
room he collapsed and then began trying
to claw his eyes out in panic and Terror
he was quickly restrained and
interrogated but he wasn't coherent
enough to give the foundation any idea
of what lurked behind the door the first
d-class to enter using
scp-004-7 the one who returned intact
and sane only said that it was a massive
room inside far bigger than the building
appeared from the outside it was
determined that the use of this key was
safe enough for further testing the door
was open again using the same key and
the foundation researchers propped it
open so that an armed team could go
inside and hopefully come out a brief
exploration of the massive room showed
some clear anomalous properties Not only
was the room impossible to measure and
possibly Limitless in size it also
seemed impossible to shine any light in
the room beyond the entry and the people
inside were the only objects that could
be felt or illuminated whatever this
room was it was keeping its Secrets it
was clear the site needed to be locked
down all the initial Witnesses Who Knew
Too Much were terminated the foundation
was a little more trigger happy with
terminations in the 40s and the site was
quickly locked down under the auspices
of being dangerous due to unexploded
ordinances fences were placed around the
site so that there would be no more
teenage Explorations the records are
spotty and incomplete but whatever
happened behind those doors during the
initial testing between 1949 and 1950.
the foundation decided it had learned
enough the space-time anomalies at play
inside of scp-004 were deemed too
dangerous to explore further and the
site was sealed off with all testing
suspended whatever was lurking behind
those doors it would keep its secrets
and the sight seemed easy to secure and
contain but this was far from the end of
scp-004 and 50 years later it made its
presence known again it was another July
night many decades after the unfortunate
teenager first opened the door to
scp-004 only a few pieces of their body
had been found but suddenly the rest of
the corpse appeared exactly where they
had last been seen outside the old
wooden door even otter was the fact that
even though the subject had died many
years ago their body was still fresh as
if they had been killed that same day
and this wouldn't be the only sudden
reappearance two days later a second
body missing parts appeared in front of
the door this was quickly identified as
one of the original 12 test subjects who
opened the door Foundation scientists
were once again sent to the site to
explore the space-time anomalies and it
was becoming clear that what went inside
the door didn't stay there it seemed
like it went somewhere that didn't exist
on this same plane as our reality and if
it could be understood it could be used
on March 21 1999 the foundation began
establishing a site inside of scp-0 004
but not for testing or research purposes
nuclear weapons around the world were
proliferating fast and evidence was
mounting that World War III could happen
soon the foundation needed a site that
could survive anything and the
Mysterious Room opened by The Rusted
Keys seemed like it could be their
salvation supplies would go in the room
and would be preserved there
indefinitely safe from even nuclear
Annihilation but getting the site set up
would pose its own challenges now dub
site 62 the facility was soon expanded
to house certain scps as well in
addition to a supercomputer to house all
Foundation data this would make it
another invaluable backup in the events
of an end of the world event that
necessitated a reboot the site was
completed over the next year during
which time they added high-tech
containment units that could hold even
the most dangerous SCP specimens
entering and exiting the facility seemed
to pose a risk to those working on it
though time no longer behave like it
should even when using the one safe key
people would spend weeks in the site
then exit claiming they'd only been
there a few days it was highly
unpredictable and the foundation
determined that it would be better to
eliminate this X Factor all Personnel
working at site 62 would now live on
site permanently with their families
being told that they had died in an
accident it was August 18 2003 when the
United States and Canada were hit with a
massive power outage knocking out power
to many of the northeast's biggest
population centers while the SCP
Foundation has backups on every site
multiple generators failed and it was 53
minutes before power could be restored
during that time those inside the
Mysterious Room were plunged into total
darkness and it soon became clear they
weren't alone in the darkened room the
Personnel reported feeling that they
were surrounded by people that shouldn't
be there and creatures that shouldn't
exist while they couldn't see anything
and nothing touched them they were
adamant that something was lurking in
the room and likely had been for a very
long time it seemed The Limited source
of life may be the only thing keeping
these entities whatever they are at Bay
when testing had resumed on scp-004
after the bodies had reappeared outside
the door the foundation decided to start
exploring the effects of
scp-004-12 as well what about this key
caused such psychological horror that
the subjects would try to tear out their
own eyes this key seemed to drive them
insane and of the 16 subjects only four
were still alive for any length of time
after their return most remained in a
catatonic state but one was given
extensive therapy and regained the
ability to communicate which allowed him
to give the foundation their best
picture yet of what lurked inside the
room while the d-class Personnel was
still severely affected by his time in
the room and suffered near total Amnesia
he did remember a few things he
remembered deep Terror and memories
being forced into his mind that made no
sense as if they were artificially
implanted and he remembered not being
alone he described a massive green being
large enough that he couldn't see where
it began and where it ended the
foundation didn't know what it was
either but what they did know for
certain is that when 10 of these keys
are used the doors opened to a dimension
where the laws of physics are so
different that it is completely
unsurvivable studies are ongoing as to
what makes this effect so fatal and if
there is a way to survive it but no
answers have been found and with only
three bodies of victims recovered so far
there is little evidence but one object
found on site is of additional interest
discovered roughly a year after the
initial anomaly in a manager's office on
the Factory grounds
scp-004-14 seems to be a miniature
version of the anomaly it's a large box
made out of wood and it is the only
other object opened by the one safe key
as well as five of the other keys that
lead to death when used on the main door
and this box has unusual properties as
well it opens automatically and much
like
scp-004's room it seems to be much
larger on the inside than the outside it
is possible to come in and out safely
but once the box is locked again it is a
different story objects placed in the
Box don't seem to affect its weight and
when the box is closed and locked they
vanish completely unlike the main room
nothing that's gone inside and locked in
has ever been recovered this includes
living beings few answers have been
found out about where they go and it's
possible the Box could be used to
dispose of specimens deemed to be too
dangerous but with no answers about
where they go and when they might come
back this may be too risky because
scp-004 is fixed in place special
containment procedures focus on making
sure it stays that way it is strictly
forbidden to take any of the other Keys
through the door for fear of losing them
or causing it to react in an
unpredictable way if the side should be
breached or anything contained in
site-62 manages to escape containment
the foundation is ready to activate the
on-site Warhead only employees with
level 1 clearance can access the site
and only level fours and above can use
the keys with all knowing that any
attempt to remove the keys from the site
will result in immediate termination for
now
scp-004 remains fenced off with only
select experiments continuing as the
foundation tries to unravel its
Mysteries but whatever lurks behind that
wooden door it keeps its secrets well
the SCP Foundation contains a mod of
monsters from scp-682 the lizard that
refuses to die to scp-939 a species of
pack Hunters that steal the voices of
their victims the dangerous predators
that occupy the hundreds of containment
cells of the foundation make it their
job to hunt and kill innocent people or
but have you ever wondered where some of
those monsters come from the first
encounter that the SCP Foundation had
with scp-4049 was on July 14th of 2010.
the foundation operates a massive
surveillance Network around the entire
world through the use of AI delegated
duties and compartmentalized information
they're able to have 911 operators
report any calls that seem anomalous in
nature while knowing nothing about the
foundation itself this way they're able
to constantly be aware of anything
anomalous going on in the country that
gets reported to 9-1-1 on July 14th the
foundation was alerted of a call that
likely had an anomalous component at
first it didn't seem like much it was a
remote address in Wyoming outside of a
small town called Gardnerville the
vacation home of one Richard Sampson a
wealthy businessman in the area placed
right on the slopes the call was made
late in the afternoon by someone
purporting to be the ground Keeper of
the home while Mr Sampson was away he
was screaming into the phone terrified
and largely incoherent but the operator
made out something about a monster
attacking the house there was a lot of
noise in the background sounds of
shouting destruction and what sounded
like animalistic Roars and grunts the
911 operator moved the call up and it
didn't take long for the foundation to
determine that something strange was
going on here they dispatched a handful
of Agents deep undercover as officers
with the Wyoming highway patrol to the
address of the home where the call had
come from after about half an hour the
agents called back into HQ the scene
they had found was nothing short of
gruesome upon arrival they were greeted
with what appeared to be the aftermath
of a particularly violent and brief
tornado the entire front section of the
ground floor had been shredded the
gardens trampled and the interior
utterly destroyed the agents picked
their way between the wreckage of the
home it functionally didn't exist
anymore the walls were collapsed from
being rammed and torn through and the
roof had collapsed in on itself the
broken shards and pieces of furniture
and wreckage were everywhere despite
appearances this wasn't a tornado a
tornado would have thrown the entire
house around now this was as the
groundskeeper had said something alive
monstrous and very angry speaking of the
groundskeeper the foundation agents
began to look for him once they took
stock of the damage of the home at first
they couldn't find him among the massive
pieces of debris and assume the worse
even if whatever had destroyed the house
decided to not kill him he could easily
have been killed by the collapsing house
buried under Rubble or a dozen other
things they picked through the ruins
calling out that they were from the
police and were here to help eventually
after another half hour of searching
they heard something what sounded like
crying and whispering became audible as
the wind died down the agents honed in
on the noise and found it was coming
from one of the larger piles of rubble
after getting some equipment they were
able to heft up the piece of the
collapsed roof and found the
groundskeeper underneath curled into a
ball and talking to himself he seemed to
be in some kind of panicked Fugue State
not responding to the agents trying to
get through to him they wrapped him in a
shock blanket and put him in the back of
one of their patrol cars but even after
that they couldn't get anything of use
out of him he was just shaking and
muttering something about monsters
eventually he was given amnestics to
forget about the incident entirely and
recovered after the agents reported back
to HQ a new issue popped up they weren't
the only ones who knew about this a News
website a few counties away had the
story the foundation quickly put out a
cover Story the house had probably been
destroyed by a group of grizzly bears
possibly rabid they had the local
government issue a warning advising
local residents to stay inside and out
of the Wilderness until the animals
could be tracked and euthanized and
that's exactly what the foundation did
mobile task force Epsilon 6 The Village
idiots an MTF that specializes in taking
on anomalous threats in remote rural
areas and small towns were dispatched to
track and contain or terminate whatever
had destroyed that Mansion the creature
had left a strong trail of tracks sent
and general destruction and the Troopers
followed it North for hours into another
dense forest where they discovered the
gigantic hulking creature wall was
asleep and shot it it was huge with
Rippling muscles on all four legs and no
fur to speak of but the most striking
feature was a frighteningly human face
the agents resolved to let the
researchers handle the autopsy and busy
themselves with the other things in that
Forest there was an old abandoned arms
Factory that the creatures seemed to
have come from the agent descended into
the decrepit abandoned building
following the creature's Trail right
into the basement there they found a
large steel door and behind it the
anomaly that would eventually be called
scp-4049 it was strange it seemed to be
some kind of massive empty room looking
up into the sky even though they were
deep underground not entirely empty the
dirt ground had a series of concentric
rings of gravestones in it all facing
inward the agents were treated once they
realized they had walked into a spatial
anomaly and called for backup the
foundation quickly flew in researchers
and a containment team to figure out
what the anomaly was and to ensure no
one else got into the factory while they
figured that out the basement of the
factory became a sort of base of
operations for the large crew of
research and security Personnel assigned
to scp-4049 after making sure there were
no other of the monsters designated
scp-4049-1 instances in the nearby
Forest the researchers began to
experiment on it they determined that
the room on the other side of the
hallway was in an extra dimensional
space members of d-class personnel were
sent in with GPS trackers and even
though they could still be heard fine on
the radio the GPS trackers failed
totally obviously the fact that you
could see the sky from an underground
room was anomalous but attempts to dig
into where the room should have been
from the surface also led to nothing but
more dirt from inside the d-class were
able to give a detailed report on the
room as they walked around it was
perfectly circular and pretty large
about 30 feet across skip or take a tall
white wall ringed the room's border and
was perfectly smooth and impossible to
get a grip on enough to climb cold hard
marble the floor of the room was in
Marble though it seemed to be regular
dirt the d-classes were ordered by
researchers to get samples of what they
could and they scooped a little dirt
into sample bags but as soon as the
subject stepped back over the threshold
into the corridor of scp-4049 the sample
bags they collected spontaneously
combusted Going Up in Flames any
chemical analysis of its composition was
of course impossible the researchers
resolved to get what information they
could of just looking at scp-4049 first
when there was still a lot to look at
the d-class inspected the rings of
gravestones inside
scp-4049 there were just two at the
moment a larger ring contained a smaller
ring inside the smaller ring there was a
circular empty space a few feet wide
most of the graves were unfilled and
unmarked just a patch of dirt turned
over but about a dozen of them had a
gravestone at their head made of that
same White marble substance the walls
were made from they weren't fancy just a
simple white rectangle stamped with some
strange symbols the d-class took photos
and sent them to the researchers who
recognized the markings as an inch word
in Greek Hound the researchers were
admittedly baffled by what this could
mean for scp-4049 but decided to figure
out the connection using the evidence
they had the corpse of the scp-4049-1
instance the researchers placed the huge
corpse inside the factory creating a
secure space to perform the autopsy then
a team of doctors began cutting into it
with scalpels or they tried anyway they
quickly realized that the skin of the
creature was far too thick to be
breached with scalpels and resorted to
Long sharpened knives they discovered
quite a few things about the instances
Anatomy along with why and how it was
able to do and absorb so much damage it
was a quadruped walking on four limbs
the forward ones seemed to be in the
shape of arms with elbows and wrists but
also had clawed paws like a dogs the
back legs were thick and heavily muscled
and digit degrade again just like a dog
so they could be you used to leap and
jump great distances once they cut away
the skin the researchers noticed that it
was indeed much thicker than they
expected it to be human skin is only
about two millimeters thick but this was
a full centimeter throughout as well as
incredibly tough and gainy internally
the structure was all wrong it seemed
almost human-like but with a few key
differences to suit the vastly changed
exterior body the spine was much thicker
and wider as well as being curved to fit
the four-legged structure there seemed
to be redundant organs the researchers
theorized they were backups like the
secondary heart they found inside the
creature's innards it could serve as a
backup if the main heart stopped working
or was damaged or it could work together
with the main heart to improve the
instance's performance during physical
activity there didn't seem to be any
kind of reproductive system it wasn't
surgically removed it just wasn't there
at all like it had magically disappeared
and inside the things
the skull was different the mouth was
much wider and larger and it didn't take
long for the researchers to figure out
why when rooting around in its mouth
they quickly discovered it had an extra
set of sharp teeth behind its main set
all unnerving slightly disturbing
discoveries but the most frightening
wasn't something they found inside the
instance it was something they noticed
immediately upon containing it its face
was human it had been morphed of course
to fit the altered skull but there were
two eyes a forehead a nose lips it was
inarguably a human face while the
researchers sent for a DNA test they
were Disturbed but not surprised to
discover what they had already been
expecting the instance was entirely
genetically human not a change species
or a close relative this creature had
once been a regular human being like you
or I the researchers had just sent the
DNA sample off to check if there was a
match in the criminal database when
suddenly the Lights Went red the doors
sealed and the site's alarms began to
sound at that moment the steel door
leading to scp-4049 flung open at
another
scp-4049-1 instance bounded out into the
corridor on all fours it set its bdis on
three members of the mobile task force
standing on the far side of the long
Corridor for a moment it didn't do
anything and it let out a long screech
that echoed around the entire Factory
its rear legs tensed up and it began to
bound down the hallway toward them all
the security guards opened fire with
their machine guns on the anomaly trying
to bring it down it Shrugged off the
bullets like there were raindrops and
didn't so much as slow down meanwhile
the two dozen other security Personnel
in the facility were rapidly grabbing
their weapons and armor from their
lockers before rocketing down the stairs
to the corridor by the time they made it
down it was too late the instance was
using its claws and Jaws to tear two of
the three poor members of the task force
to shreds it wasn't eating them but it
was attacking them with enough anger and
Malice that there wasn't going to be
much left when it was done the third
member of the task force had fallen and
was backing away from the anomaly in
fear the remaining members of the task
force opened fire smothering the
scp-4049-1 instance in a hail of bullets
the sudden overwhelming Firepower caught
it off guard and after a few seconds of
sustained gunfire it fell to the ground
dead once the foundation realized the
active danger that scp-4049 presented
they decided not to take any chances
with containment the 50 meter long
Corridor leading to scp-4049 from the
basement elevator was fortified and
airlock was installed on the far side
separating it from the rest of the
factory then motion detectors were set
every few meters throughout the hallway
attached to a series of deterrence if an
scp-4049-1 instant smashed out of the
steel door trip the alarms and activate
everything from a supersonic sound
Cannon to sentry guns and a machine gun
and placement and if none of those
worked the entire Corridor could be
pumped full of nerve gas guaranteeing
the death of the instance without
risking the lives of any Personnel this
kill Corridor was to be guarded by the
applied task force Iota 9 to ensure that
no
scp-4049-1 instance would survive its
Escape but after the corridor was
retrofitted the foundation had a bigger
problem where were these
scp-4049-1 instances coming from to
begin with they performed another DNA
test on the new instance its face was
different so it seemed logical that it
was a different person when the results
came back the researchers were surprised
to find that not just one but both of
the samples had DNA matches in the
National Database both were men from the
tri-state area who had mysteriously died
or disappeared in the past few months
while at some kind of religious service
they were both Avid big game Hunters
with an interest in shooting moose bears
and elk and most important they had both
been the subject of a fire related
incident one had been presumed dead when
his house burned down the other had
simply vanished with this car being
found hours later on fire by the side of
the highway in both cases a body was
never recovered but the authorities did
find a strange stone-tipped Arrow driven
into the ground nearby over the
following months the foundation observed
a number of these strange events
happening in Wyoming Idaho and Montana
and like clockwork every time it
happened a new headstone appeared over
one of the previously unmarked Graves
inside
scp-4049 saying the same Greek word
Hound on top of all of that almost every
time a man in the area disappeared under
these specific circumstances and the
grave was created an
scp-4049-1 instance would appear inside
scp-4049 sometime in following two
months buried within the soil Circle in
the center of the room it would clot its
way out of the dirt smash open the steel
door to scp-4049 and race down the
hallway trying to kill and destroy
whatever was in front of it until it was
gunned down but in one instance that
didn't happen on September 17th of 2015
the foundation had gotten into the
rhythm of containing scp-4049 so they
weren't startled or caught off guard
when an agent with the highway patrol
reported finding a flaming truck near a
hunting ground and the bed was an El
carcass with a stone-tipped arrow
launched deep into the meat applied task
force Iota 9 at the factory began to
prepare for an imminent appearance from
an scp-4049-1 entity within the
following weeks and established a
round-the-clock guard in the kill
Corridor but it never came by December
nothing had happened at all the
foundation made the decision a d-class
would be sent into scp-4049 with a
camera and radio in the hopes of
manually initiating the event to occur
the d-class subject wasn't given very
specific instructions just fitted with a
body camera a two-way radio and told to
listen to All instructions on the
headset the researchers ordered him
forward until he reached the other side
of the hallway where he was to open the
steel door leading to scp-4049 and enter
when he entered everything looked the
same as the foundation expected it to
the same gravestones walls and dirt he
moved towards the center of the room to
the dirt Circle but suddenly stopped
looking around when the researchers
asked why he reported hearing the sound
of dogs barking for a moment before the
researchers told him to keep walking
when he stopped in the center of the
room he again radioed in feeling that
someone was there the camera didn't pick
anyone up but he insisted that there was
an odd feeling just before the audio
stream suddenly cut out a burst of
static interference drowned everything
else
slowly winded down the d-class couldn't
be heard anymore but a strange female
voice was on the line speaking to the
foundation she mentioned that the
foundation had been ruining her pets for
far too long the foundation demanded the
speaker identify themselves but she just
scoffed indignant at what she called
human arrogance right after that all
audio feeds were cut out permanently
this mysterious woman was designated as
scp-4049-2 seven seconds after they cut
out the largest
scp-4049-1 instance ever recorded exited
scp-4049 standing at almost 11 meters
high all the deterrents were activated
but even then it still took all of them
combined with machine gun fire from the
applied task force to bring the creature
down no remains of the d-class and no
traces of whoever was speaking on the
radio were ever found by the researchers
it can be dangerous to stand between
someone and their oven plants did you
ever have to perform a dissection in
school maybe you had to carve up a fetal
pig or slice into a frog while
nightmarish visions of Kermit and a
widowed Miss Piggy danced in your head
though it's rarely a pleasant experience
unless your tastes are on The Morbid
side most biology teachers would agree
that the best way to learn how something
works is to take it apart as distasteful
as it can be to hold a frog's tiny liver
in your hands it definitely does give
you a better sense of the pieces that
make up the complete creature but what
if there was an easier way to look at
the individual parts of a living being
what if you could take it apart without
ever having to prep a scalpel or stain
your hands with the blood of innocent
frogs like most of the seemingly
impossible things in our world the SCP
Foundation discovered something that
allows its users to do just that in fact
it can handle a lot more than just a
frog and its applications go far beyond
the confines of a high school science
lab
scp-291 is is a small plane steel
building with a large door on one side
the door has no handle or knob and
functions similarly to a garage door the
door cannot be pried open by any
ordinary means and the inside of scp-291
can only be accessed if the structure is
connected to a suitable power source
once a power source has been connected
the door races and exposes a room inside
it is small about four by two meters it
contains a console board a large screen
and a Plexiglas container resembling a
coffin how very Sinister the coffin is
large enough to contain a human under
seven feet tall so sorry Ferdinand the
cannibal you're going to need to sit
this one out the coffin sits on a
conveyor belt with several tubes
connected to the wall above it on the
opposite side of the room there are
holes of varying sizes each containing a
small door that can be opened or closed
because initial observation indicated
that scp-291 was intended for some kind
of human testing a d-class test subject
was selected for experimentation the
subject was instructed to lie down in
the coffin and wait to see what would
happen next the display screen lit up
depicting a gridlined image of the test
subject buttons along the console board
adjusted the image showing the skin
muscles and organ systems of the person
in the coffin there were no words or
numbers on the screen and all of the
buttons appeared to have only two
settings on and off when one of the
researchers pressed the first button on
the console the tubes above the coffin
began pouring a blue liquid into it the
test subject reacted with confusion but
did not experience any adverse effects
they quickly lost Consciousness
indicating that the liquid was some sort
of sedative the liquid continued to pour
into the coffin until the vessel was
completely filled at which point it
congealed into a thick gel the test
subject's breathing and heartbeat slowed
to a stop and the conveyor belt suddenly
creaked to life the coffin was carried
test subject inside through a small door
that immediately locked behind it the
small room was filled with the sounds of
Gears turning Machinery clinking and
Motors whirring the display screen was
taken over by a large rectangle
resembling a traditional loading screen
after 30 minutes the process was
complete and the back door of the room
unlocked itself when the researcher
walked through the back door they found
another room with a conveyor belt and a
row of two dozen lockers each Locker was
opened one at a time and its contents
removed for examination inside each the
research team found a different portion
of the test subject's body in a block of
some unidentified clear substance the
body was divided in the lockers into
these separate parts brain lungs and
diaphragm heart digestive system
reproductive organs left eye right eye
upper left torso and arm upper right
torso and arm lower left torso and upper
leg lower right torso and upper leg
lower left leg and foot lower right leg
and foot lower left arm in hand lower
right arm and hand neck and head upper
skeletal system lower skeletal system
lymphatic and circulatory system and
skin
the miracle of the human body right
boundless in its fascinating
complexities each block of body parts
was placed back in its designated locker
and the second button on the console was
pressed at this point the doors to the
organ lockers sealed themselves shut and
the sound of the Machinery working
filled the small space once again this
continued for a duration of
approximately 45 minutes when the
Machinery went silent a new Plexiglas
coffin emerged into the main room with
the test subject inside he looked
identical to how he had looked at the
start of the experiment with no evidence
that he had previously been disassembled
the blue liquid slowly evaporated from
the container and the test subject
opened his eyes the lead researcher
conducted an immediate interview with
the reassembled subject who reported no
memory of the process after initial
exposure to the blue liquid they
insisted that the process had been like
a good night's sleep which honestly
makes us pretty eager to take it for a
spin a medical examination determined
that there were only a few changes to
the test subject during the disassembly
and reassembly when they returned to
Consciousness the test subject's stomach
was empty they were naked and all of
their hair was Gone with this new
understanding of scp-291's anomalous
properties the foundation decided to
continue their experimentation with each
new test the experiments became more
creative and unsurprisingly more
depraved first a d-class subject was
placed in the coffin and disassembled
then instead of placing the various body
parts in their designated lockers the
vital organs were removed from their
storage before reassembly was attempted
this resulted in the equipment shutting
down completely a researcher pressed the
third button which forced a hard reset
of the entire process causing all the
blocks of body parts to eject via an
exit hatch during the next experiment
non-vital organs were removed before the
subject's body was reassembled the
appendix and gallbladder were left out
and when the subject regained
Consciousness these organs were still
gone however there was no visible damage
or scar tissue in their place they were
simply gone as if they have never been
there in the first place so if body
parts could be removed from a test
subject could new body parts be added
could existing body parts be replaced
with different ones a d-class subject in
need of a skin graft following a
flamethrower-based accident was placed
in scp-291 once taken apart a portion of
healthy skin donated by another somewhat
unwilling d-class subject was placed in
the locker along with the skin already
present there once the subject was put
back together the healthy skin had
replaced the damaged skin with no
adverse effects repeat attempts at this
test showed that it was effective for
limb transplants heart transplants and
kidney transplants with a zero percent
failure rate across all tests after
determining that scp-291 could be used
for an Untold amount of good making
organ donations easier and safer than
ever the foundation naturally had to
Pivot to something more useless but
interesting and likely horrifying after
all it's not like they could ever just
make anomalous technology available to
the public right two d-class subjects
one man and one woman were disassembled
by scp-291 the brains of the test
subjects were swapped and then they were
reassembled when they awoke the subjects
had the personalities and memories of
the brain placed in their body in a turn
of events previously only seen in
blockbuster comedies like Freaky Friday
and the live-action Scooby-Doo movie
seminal piece of Cinema the subjects had
swapped bodies they were subsequently
disassembled their request to look at
their new bodies naked having been
swiftly denied and the brains were
returned to their rightful bodies after
the experiment was finished the subjects
appeared mostly normal however they did
complain of disorientation as well as
mental and physical Comfort over the
next several days after going through
two brain transplants in one day though
that's really the least you can expect
after perfecting the practice of
swapping body parts between different
human subjects the ghoulishly Curious
research team decided to take things in
an inter-species Direction a variety of
test subjects including cats dogs
lizards fish mice and of course humans
were selected for this next round of
experiments 20 tests were performed
using these new subjects and only three
of the experiments were successful in
transferring body parts from an animal
of one species to another animal of a
different one attempts to swap body
parts between mammals and reptiles or
fish prove disastrous when a fish and a
human were both disassembled and the
fish's gills were placed with the humans
body parts neither creature survived the
reassembly process the human awoke with
a new set of gills embedded in their
neck and immediately began gasping for
the oxygen they could not take in within
they had suffocated the fish's fate was
even worse it did not reassemble so much
as it became a pile of goo scales and
two floating eyeballs experimentation
with a human and a lizard yielded
similar results turning the lizard into
a puddle of organic matter and killing
the human test subject after only a few
minutes as disastrous as the failed
cross species tests were the successful
ones were almost as bad trial 001
involved a cat and a human not wanting
to attempt too much at once the research
team opted to just swap out one organ
the left eye both subjects survived the
transfer and were able to use their new
eye the human subject reported full use
of the cat's eye with improved night
vision in addition to trouble seeing
color the cat did not enjoy its new eye
nearly as much as the human subject and
had clawed its human eye out of its head
by the end of the following week in
trial 007 a successful brain transfer
was performed between an adult human man
and an English Mastiff the man in the
Mastiff's body expressed discomfort with
walking on all fours and asked to be
returned to his body as soon as possible
the mastiff in the man's body adjusted
to bipedal locomotion in a few hours but
was disassembled after urinating on a
researcher's shoes the final successful
trial and the most unnerving was trial
zero one six a female d-class test
subject's reproductive organs were
swapped with those of a pregnant
Labrador Retriever an ultrasound
conducted after the transfer indicated
that the labrador fetuses survived the
procedure and could conceivably be
carried to term by the human subject
several members of the research team
began to take bets on whether or not she
would end up giving birth to puppies but
the transfer was reversed within the day
so we'll never know what exactly would
have happened perhaps that's for the
best personally we hope the foundation's
Ethics Committee gives some of these
scientists a very Stern talking to about
their behavior on this one when not in
use for testing
scp-291 is to be disconnected from any
power our sources at least two Personnel
are positioned outside of its
containment at all times standing guard
and these personnel must be swapped out
every week when it is not connected to
any power sources scp-291 is considered
harmless though it should still be
treated with caution the main entryway
remains closed and locked when there is
no available power source but the door
can be opened manually from the inside
in the event of an emergency any
disassembled organisms are stored in the
locker in the containment facility
labeled with a sharpie marker in order
to keep track of what specimens are
stored there whether this is the same
Sharpie used to label food in the break
room fridge is unknown but just like Dr
D Romero's ham sandwich it's best to
leave these items untouched any
Personnel found to be responsible for
missing specimens will be transferred to
another project and receive a strongly
worded email hey do you have a favorite
reality show oh come on don't lie
everyone has one Dr clef loves some of
American Ninja Warrior and I've got it
on good authority that Dr bright can't
get enough of the bachelor so how about
you huh do you obsessively follow the
Romantic highs and lows of Love island
or are you more of the type who likes to
curl up with a mug of hot cocoa and
enjoy a nice wholesome episode of The
Great British baking show do you ever
yell at the TV when the contestants on
Jeopardy just can't get the answer right
do you get a kick out of seeing what
crazy Collectibles will show up on this
week's episode of Pawn Stars if you
answered yes to any of these you're not
alone millions of people around the
world still tune in to all kinds of
reality TV personally I just can't get
enough of my favorite hidden camera show
laugh is fun what's that you've never
heard of laugh is fun no
oh boy you're really missing out if you
like reality TV you're going to love
laugh is fun laugh is fun also known as
scp-2030 isn't a show that you can watch
on TV instead it appears as the most
popular form of media distribution in
the current year today you can find it
on file sharing and streaming websites
but in the 2000s you could rent it from
the DVD kiosk at the mall and back in
the 90s it used to show up as
multi-taped sets in video rental stores
even though the SCP Foundation has only
been aware of lapis fun since 1993. it
has a recorded 38 Seasons as of 2014
meaning that it may have existed in some
form as far back as the 1970s if you
want to binge all 38 Seasons you might
also want to look it up under the names
laugh is life or in some countries laugh
is laugh and if you happen to be in a
country where laugh is laugh isn't
available you may want to try changing
your location using a VPN to one where
you can access it oh what's that you
don't have a VPN service well then I'm
glad you're here because before we go
any further I have a very important word
from our sponsor who just so happens to
be ignored VPN the preferred VPN service
of all the researchers here at SCP
explained sign up now at nordvpn.com
forward slash SCP explained nordvpn
isn't just a VPN it's truly the best VPN
available with a simple click you'll be
able to access content that might be
blocked just because of your location so
you'll never have to miss an episode of
your favorite anomalous television
programs but wait there's more much much
more what if you're right in the middle
of binge watching of season 31 when
suddenly your quality dips to looking
like a couple of blurry blocks or
fighting over an old shoebox never fear
because nordvpn encrypts all of your
traffic that means your internet service
provider can throttle your service and
slow down your streaming speed you
should never settle for less than the
highest quality pixels after all and it
doesn't matter how you choose to watch
nordvpn is available on every modern
platform including Windows iOS Android
Mac OS Linux and even Android TV the
monthly cost is the same as a cup of
coffee regular coffee that is not the
kind that comes from scp-294 and if you
sign up by going to nordvpn.com forward
slash SCP explained you'll even get a
free month so go try it for yourself
right now that's nordvpn.com forward
slash SCP explained now back to your
regularly scheduled programming as we
were saying laugh is fun is a prank show
that puts a knowing everyday people into
ridiculous scenarios and films their
reactions each episode is about 10 to 12
minutes long and features an opening and
closing monologue from beloved
supposedly Human TV vpresenter laughing
mclafferson AKA
scp-2030-1 you've probably seen him
before he's never seen without his blue
three-piece suit and black wingtip shoes
funniest guy on TV seriously I think he
should replace James Corden on The Late
Late Show and maybe even take up hosting
a gig on SNL if he's still got time
after he had this amazing monologue at
the end of an episode in season 32.
all right off folks we've seen printers
that eat eaters that print and
everything in between makes you
appreciate the old clunker you have at
the back office doesn't it no printers
may not always work when you want or
need them to but they sure make for some
excellent comedy and that's what we're
all about here comedy we're here to make
you laugh we hope you laugh thank you
for laughing with us that's what we're
about here doesn't it folks come laugh
with us again next time and remember
laugh is fun good night and laugh and
laugh just laugh we love the make laugh
make more for laughter so as two for
laugh laugh with us laugh with us laugh
with us laugh with us laugh with us
laugh with us laugh laugh laugh laugh
and let us in hmm I couldn't tell you
what his face looks like though because
he's always framed from the neck down
once the pranks are done for the episode
he'll step up on that bright yellow
stage and deliver his closing monologue
which always ends with a pan over the
audience as everyone chance laugh with
us then the show always just cuts to
Black the closest thing the show ever
has to credits is a title card that says
filmed in front of a studio audience in
partnership with
ywtgthft for a show that doesn't
advertise or even air on TV laugh is fun
is still a beloved classic and when you
watch it it's easy to see why it's been
around so long laffy and the team pull
off some really classic pranks on laugh
is laugh there's this one episode in
season 13 where an unsuspecting family
is sitting down to dinner father starts
choking and the family reacts with
horror until suddenly a pair of slits
appear in the father's neck allowing him
to breathe those sleds soon become
nostrils and before you know it a full
second head grows out of his neck that
head then grows its own neck which grows
in noose than a face than another head
than another neck this keeps happening a
total of 18 times while the rest of the
family looks on in horror but don't
worry before things go too far laffy
pops out from under the table and tells
the family they're on laugh is fun
laughy points out the cameras and the
whole family starts laughing including
all 18 of the father's heads there's
also another great season 13 episode
called squirrels oh man okay this one
had me in stitches alright so there's
this couple lying in bed and the wife
wakes up because she hears this
squeaking noise she Taps her husband on
the shoulder to wake him up but she
draws her hand back in horror because
she can feel something moving under her
husband's Skin So before she can ask if
he's okay boom hundreds of squirrels
explode out of his skin and start
running around the room while the wife
screams then laugh he walks in and turns
the lights on accompanied by the husband
who is perfectly okay even though he's
been skinned from head to toe everyone
laughs alright then there's the most
recent episode from season 24 called
swelling there's this old lady sitting
on a park bench feeding the pigeons and
a couple walks past her when they walked
past the old lady gets swarmed by the
pigeon she's feeding the pigeons Force
themselves into her mouth and keep
swarming until her stomach cavity bursts
open the couple who gets sprayed with
guts as to all the pigeons fly off are
extremely distressed by this until laffy
shows up some people say that this
episode is too similar to squirrels and
that the show was starting to get stale
at this point but I think the joke is
unique enough to stand on its own plus
with a prank show as long running as
left it's inevitable that you're gonna
see some jokes get reused really it's
not about the prank itself it's about
the reactions of the people which are
always Priceless and man the way that
laffy mclafferson comes into the frame
by climbing out of the old lady's open
rib cage I was rolling on the floor now
you don't think the old animals
exploding out of people that is funny
okay that's fair enough uh let me think
what are some of my other favorite
episodes of laugh is fun oh yes the
Margaret Thatcher episode from season
21. that's another great thing about
laugh is fun it's not afraid to get a
little political so this woman walks
into your kitchen and opens the cabinet
but instead of the food being in there
it's just a Big Blob of Flesh the flesh
blob rolls out onto the counter and
morphs into a misshapen caricature of
Margaret Thatcher with a
disproportionately big head the woman
starts screaming but the Thatcher
creature jumps onto her pinning her down
and shoving its tongue into her mouth
the deeper the tongue goes the more
Margaret Thatcher faces start appearing
all over the woman's skin all the faces
start reciting Thatcher's April 1986
speech on the bombing of Libya and
perfect Unison you might watch it and
think the woman's going to choke based
on how long the creature's tongue is
down her throat but good old laugh he
comes in and the studio audience goes
nuts laffy points out the cameras and
says your own life is fun and the woman
starts laughing too with a creature's
tongue still in her mouth but I think my
favorite prank I've ever seen on laugh
is fun was the one from season 37 so
it's in a hospital there's a woman
getting a C-section and all the doctors
are gathered around one of the doctors
makes a comment on how much hair the
baby has and then he screams and drops
his surgical tools the rest of the team
all starts screaming as well and then
this is where it's really funny you see
Ryan Seacrest's head pop up from out of
the woman okay so this is causing her a
lot of pain obviously so she starts
screaming and crying as the Ryan
Seacrest head fully emerges at which
point you can tell that its head is on
an octopus body classic bait and switch
right but that's not the end the Ryan
Seacrest octopus starts singing row row
row your boat as it emerges and then
three more octopi with celebrities heads
come out of this woman there's one that
looks like Jack Nicholson one that looks
like Johnny Cash and one who looks like
Martin Freeman and when they've all come
out of her they start singing together
in four-part harmony it's hilarious
laughy walks in to point out the cameras
and all the doctors start laughing even
the woman on the operating table is
laughing in fact she laughs so hard she
passes out it's a real shame that there
are never any end credits because it
would be so cool to find out more about
the people who make this show I mean
their total comedic Geniuses and special
effects Wizards too I couldn't even
guess how they do some of those pranks
but sadly there's very little
information about the Show online and
you you can't even ask the victims of
the pranks about it because all of them
are dead what no no no no no not because
of laugh is fun that's just a prank show
it's all jokes they always show everyone
laughing and perfectly okay at the end
no matter how badly they got mutilated
in the episode you can even see some
people who have been on previous
episodes among the studio audiences if
you look hard enough but okay by total
coincidence everyone who is featured on
laugh is fun eventually dies or is
already dead of totally unrelated causes
like the Turman family dad Gary Turman
was the one who had 18 extra heads grow
out of his neck Gary his wife Lindsay
and their two kids tragically passed
away in a car wreck on the 28th of April
1989. Melissa and Travis younglin the
couple from the squirrel prank went
missing and were last seen on the 12th
of May 1989. the couple from the pigeon
prank Macy Gershon and Kyle Parker were
both killed by a hit-and-run driver in
September of 2000. Doris Carter the
woman from the Thatcher prank passed
away from ovarian cancer in 1997 and
Rebecca Nash the woman who gave birth to
all those singing celebrity cephalopods
died in childbirth in 2013. you might
think that the last one had something to
do with her laugh is fun episode due to
the hospital connection but the
surgeon's present when she died didn't
report anything strange happening at the
time all these deaths happen in roughly
the same years that all these people had
their appearances on laugh but it's
because it's only available on streaming
and video it can't really be said what
the connection is since there aren't any
air dates for any of the episodes while
you might assume that these people died
after their appearances on laugh and the
show is actually some kind of death
curse it's just as likely that they died
before and laugh is fun is somehow
filmed and distributed from the great
beyond some people even think that the
people who film laugh actually kidnap
all the people who appear on the show
and fake their deaths in some kind of
big Sinister conspiracy sure I have
heard that all the people who supposedly
died after being on the show have
inconsistencies in their death records
and that many of their graves actually
just told empty coffins but still that
feels totally unrealistic to me I mean
come on can you really picture TV's own
laughy laugherson kidnapping anyone he
has such a friendly attitude like I said
before no information whatsoever exists
about the way this show is made not even
the SCP Foundation has any answers
they're still actively investigating the
ways in which people get chosen to be on
laugh as fun as well as where it's
filmed and who produces it talk about a
really Niche cult hit I hope I've sold
you on laugh as fun it may not be that
well known and you might have trouble
finding it but trust me it's the
funniest prank show you'll probably ever
watch I guarantee once you get into it
it'll make you laugh and laugh and laugh
laugh with us laugh with us laugh with
us laugh with us on April 16 1999 the
Raleigh Ripper was finally brought to
Justice after a reign of terror across
the state of North Carolina that left 14
women dead the Killer's true identity
had been Kevin Gruber a local gas
station attendant originally from West
Virginia who was arrested at work in the
early hours of the morning his face was
plastered all over the media when he was
cuffed and dragged in to be questioned
and processed like many serial killers
the most frightening thing about Kevin
was the fact that he just seemed so
normal the idea that a person like this
could have committed the atrocities of
the Raleigh Ripper raised a frightening
question we all need to contend with
what turns a person into a monster this
question was particularly prescient for
Dr James Whittington a criminal
psychologist tasked with conducting the
first official psychological evaluation
on Gruber ever since the true identity
of the killer had come to light the case
had held a particular Fascination for
him mainly because Gruber the man and
Gruber the killer seemed to almost be
too entirely separate people according
to all evidence the Raleigh Ripper was
an Insidious methodical criminal genius
he'd stock some of his victims all women
who lived alone for weeks before
striking conducting detailed
surveillance of their homes that allowed
him to isolate them bypassed their
security systems and remove any means of
getting help he blocked doors cut phone
lines and always selected vulnerable
targets despite being a seasoned
criminal psychologist the actual details
of gruber's crimes had kept Whittington
awake at night he had a wife and a young
son at home and the thought of a man
like Gruber prowling out there made him
fear for both of them this was no thrill
killer he was a sadistic torturer who
seemed to Delight in the pain and Terror
of his prey he chosen victims he could
take his time with infiltrated their
homes like a gust of cold air through an
open window and slipped out through
Darkness like a shadow perfectly
controlled crime scenes No stray
evidence nothing but death Left Behind
for months he'd run circles around the
police thousands of people who fit the
Raleigh Ripper profile were interviewed
sting operations were conducted
communities formed neighborhood watches
to keep each other safe from the
Killer's next move and none of it did
any good from seasoned detectives to
Legions of beat cops nobody could get
the jump on Kevin Gruber the fact he was
even caught came out of pure chance a
local hiker Mike Fletcher just so
happened to hear the screaming coming
from a nearby Home in the woods and made
the heroic decision to run in and
intervene when he walked in on Gruber
committing the attack the killer
panicked and fled through an open window
in his haste he'd left a partial print
on the window frame that combined with
Mike's description of the assailant was
enough to finally link Kevin to the 14
murders of the Raleigh Ripper the
problem from Dr whittington's effective
was that by all accounts Kevin Gruber
seemed to be an idiot this was no Suave
charismatic Ted Bundy type in all the
prior photos and interviews Kevin had
that deer in the headlights look of a
man who's just in way over his head Dr
Whittington had also poured over Kevin's
school records the only thing he seemed
to excel at was being mediocre he even
got held back a year in fifth grade
since graduating high school he'd been
kicked out by his parents for
freeloading and hadn't been able to
consistently hold down a job for more
than eight months his only prior
criminal convictions had been one drunk
and disorderly conduct charge and
possession of an ounce of pot back in
1991 for which he got a suspended
sentence due to being a minor at the
time it just didn't make sense to Dr
Whittington that this man and the
diabolically brilliant Raleigh Ripper
were the same person despite all the
incontrovertible evidence proving it so
despite his reservations he needed did
to meet this man and find out why and
how he committed all these horrific
murders despite being such an
unremarkable individual sitting across
from Gruber in the secure interview
chamber Woodington was once again struck
with how incredibly disappointing he was
Finn and wiry with glazed over eyes
messy hair and a pathetic tuft of weak
stubble on his chin he looked more like
Shaggy from Scooby-Doo than a
cold-blooded killer his answers to most
of Dr whittington's questions were also
insubstantial with him often losing his
train of thought or even needing to ask
the psychologist to carefully explain
the question to him most of the time
Gruber tried to make irritating slow
motion Small Talk concerning everything
from the weather to movies he enjoyed
the interview had been utterly worthless
until four hours in Gruber mentioned
something that awakened a strange memory
in Dr Whittington he said hey say Doc
you remember that TV show Bobble the
clown I love that show as a kid it was
like my religion you could ever watch it
there were a number of unsettling things
about this from the fact that for some
reason Dr Whittington could remember
something about Bobble the clown to the
fact that Kevin Gruber had no way of
knowing that Dr Whittington even had a
kid but still he didn't let his concern
show and instead asked Gruber what he
remembered about Bobble the clown Guru
smiled and replied all Bobble taught me
everything I know doc to which Dr
Whittington asked the million dollar
question like what Kevin Gruber shruggin
just said all kinds of stuff doc like
how to watch without being seen had a
Jimmy open a window without making a
sound how to make him hurt real bad
without him dying see he could even make
it last longer so it can be more fun and
of course he taught me to get out
without leaving anything behind well
Bobble made this all possible Doc and he
told me all about you too that all this
was gonna happen someday all good things
have to come to an end eventually right
tell the wife and kid he says hi by the
way Dr Whittington was astounded Gruber
seemed to stare vacantly off into space
for a moment before suddenly claiming
that he had a terrible headache and he
needed to go back to his cell in any
other situation Whittington might have
just written off Bobble the clown as one
of two things a psychotic delusion or a
sophisticated psychopath faking a
psychotic delusion in hopes of getting
the insanity plea like the son of sand
killer David Berkowitz pretending a
demonic talking dog possessed by Satan
made him commit all of his murders but
Whittington had heard of this Bobble the
clown before and it wasn't in the
scenario that a gas station clerk like
Kevin Gruber ever would have heard of it
took half a day of research into his own
archive notes to remember exactly where
he'd heard it before a child he'd
interviewed almost a decade ago who
shoved gasoline and fireworks through
the letterbox of an old woman's home
leading to a fire that left the woman
and her dog dead when Dr Whittington
interviewed the crying child about his
motives he'd said that it wasn't his
fault Bobble the clown had told them to
do it on the TV given that there were no
records of a bobble the clown show ever
airing on any local networks Whittington
had written it off at the time as the
overactive imagination of a very
frightened very disturbed young child
that same child would later go into
psychiatric care before reoffending as a
serial arsonist upon release the last
building he ever burned down had only
one occupant himself fire investigators
would later state that he had just sat
there legs crossed plastically waiting
for the Flames to lick his bones clean
it was becoming incredibly clear that
this Bobble the clown fantasy if it were
even a fantasy at all seemed to be much
more than an isolated phenomenon he used
his credentials to start exploring other
strange Crimes of Passion committed by
children and young adults even asking
some of his friends in the criminal
psychology Community off the Record if
they'd ever heard of such a concept
before frighteningly it didn't take Dr
Whittington very long at all to hit Pay
Dirt there was the case of the arfio
family murders in 1985 out in Arkansas
nine-year-old Donnie orfeo had taken his
dad's rifle out of the cabinet in the
dead of night and walked room to room
shooting his mother father and two older
sisters in their beds neighbors had
heard the gunshots and called the police
by the time they arrived at the scene
the only Survivor was Donnie orfeo
himself drenched in blood sitting in
front of the TV his hollow eyes stared
zombie-like into the static he did not
resist arrest when Dany was taken in for
questioning his emotional responses were
cold and flat when he was asked why he
murdered his family he said that it was
because his father told him he was
watching too much TV his favorite TV
character Bobble the clown had told him
that if he murdered his family with
Daddy's gun he could watch as much TV as
he liked just reading this Dr
Whittington could feel sweat beating on
his brow two cases were a coincidence
but three were a pattern and know how he
wish it had stopped at just three from
four days of searching he discovered no
fewer than 17 different seemingly
isolated crimes with mentions of Bobble
the clown attached to the file a
five-year-old boy from New Jersey who
drowned his neighbor's cat in a river
with a gym bag full of heavy Stones told
police that he'd learned the technique
from Bobble the clown an eight-year-old
girl arrested for tying up and torturing
her sister with a rusty coat hanger in
Texas had of course gotten the idea from
watching an episode of Bobble the clown
murder assault vandalism torture an
extensive Country-Wide rap sheet all LED
back to that one recurring Factor they
all learned it from watching Bobble the
clown Dr Whittington had gotten in
contact with a few friends who knew
people in broadcasting while carefully
emitting some of the grizzlier details
he implored them for any new information
on whether a TV show with Bobble the
clown had ever gone out anywhere but
despite their best efforts they didn't
find any records of Bobble the clown or
any similar educational clown shows
airing was it possibly some complex
shared hallucination Dr Whittington
simultaneously felt burdened by all this
terrifying knowledge and utterly
powerless to do anything useful with it
if he started blowing the whistle to the
media or his superiors that a spat of
horrible crimes were all being caused by
a violent imaginary clown he'd just look
as deranged as any of the people he'd
been studying there seemed to be nothing
he could do to stop or help any of this
he returned home that night with a heavy
heart hanging up his coat he needed
someone to talk to about all this but he
couldn't burden his wife with the
horrors he encountered daily on the job
much less a living nightmare air like
this mysterious Bobble the clown as he
walked towards the kitchen to pour
himself a stiff drink he heard Strange
jaunting Music coming from the living
room he stepped back and saw his
seven-year-old son Ben watching
something on TV as he stepped closer he
could scarcely believe his eyes Ben
entranced eyes fixed on a dancing
grinning animated clown on the screen
Ben slowly turned his head towards Dr
Whittington eyes wide and bulging and
said I've been waiting for you to get
home Daddy Bobble said he got tired of
playing with Kevin he wants to play with
us now Dr Whittington turned and looked
at the clown on the screen again he
could swear it was smiling right at him
that was the last thing he remembered
before the sudden intense headache and
the ground standing up to embrace him
when he woke up he was in bed with his
wife and neither of them could move
thanks to the heavy ropes binding their
body to the frame Bobble is very good at
teaching children to tie knots they
tried to scream but a shiny flash of
duct tape held both of their mouths
closed Dr whittington's eyes swiveled in
his head to Ben standing at his bedside
the boy was holding a kitchen knife and
he was very eager to show his mom and
dad the fun new trick Bobble the clown
had taught him to the SCP Foundation
this terrifying anomalous TV show is
known as
scp-993 known to cause blackouts in
adults and violent anti-social behavior
in children they do their best to keep
the broadcasts contained but if ever a
child in your life seems to be acting
strangely perhaps ask yourself very
carefully what they're watching when
you're not around now go check out the
secret at the bottom of scp-087
explained and procedure 110 Montauk
revealed fear alone as C p231 tail for
more harrowing Tales of anomalous Terror